Okay.
You have a neighbor that is dying for me
to introduce you to him. Really? Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
You go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name.
Rogan doodled get 15% off
the number one sex toy from men
and also Alpha brain from on it,
o n n I t.com as of Alpha brand.
And we have a new product out called
shroom tech, something with mushrooms,
but I'm not sold on it yet.
I've only tried it a couple
of times. Um, anyway, uh,
if you go to that website and
entering rogue and you get 10% off,
I'm just saving you money bitches all
around bird crises in the house and we're
fend to get busy
different
[inaudible]
that soundtrack.
It's going to be responsible for some
ringing in my ears when I'm an old man.
I know that it can't be good for you.
Whoa,
whoa. It comes into abrupt ending
getting crappy today with all new things.
The Alpha brain, is that what it is? It's
tweaked you have you taken a Brian? Yeah.
You know what I was, I tweeted something
the other day that I, right after I did,
I'm like, you know, that actually is
not a given. Probably a good thing,
but it is a good thing. Like I sounded
good. I feel like I need Alpha brain now.
You feel like you're addicted to it?
Kind of, but it's like addictive.
Not for a bad reason. It's addictive for
a clearheaded reason. Like almost like,
hey, I should have been on prescription
drugs the whole time, you know,
but I'm not, you know what I mean?
If you've got on the real shit,
why don't you get on the real one?
Don't go to a doctor and see it might have
something for you that works. Awesome.
Yeah.
I mean you might be like wrestling with
life and you might just go to some place
and they might be,
if you've seen his beard.
Beard is like to the homeless. Yeah,
it's, there's carrot juice in it too.
I could taste it. I think it looks like
you don't give a fuck. I like that look.
Definitely looks like it
doesn't mean what it looks like.
The guy was a relaxed job.
I was just on Rachael Ray the other day.
I trim the shit out of mind like, yeah,
like I was a black football player,
like downlines here a little longer here.
I don't know if I like manscaping.
I was thinking about manscaping
in my girl's like, no,
I like the crazy homeless look
like I like it looks like you're,
you're the one that's, I know you've
got a good one girl. White facial hair.
Like any girl wants you to shave
all that. Oh, shave all that.
That's a broken bitch.
I want that one in your life.
Have you noticed like when he shaved like
underneath your Chin and it starts to
grow back just a teeny bit like a
five o'clock shadow. It looks weird.
It looks like you're a kid. You can't
over aggressively make the jaw line right.
Then you look like one of the gay
guys that just trying to look skinny.
The steam room. You, my wife was
like, you need to grow that shit out.
I had great beard trimming advice guys
who tried to look skinny eligible.
That's at least what I thought
when they walked by me.
So this is like the outline
of the Jawbone, is that what
it is? But not even really.
It's like where they've wished the job
on where it's like Bob from biggest loser
used to rock that shit.
He's totally gelled on
a Christian Asheville.
Carolina, you were on a quick Christian
rock station in Asheville. Right.
And they were like keep it a Christian.
And I was like been Christian. They said
that's the opposite of stay black.
Cause the exact opposite of stay black,
Cuban Christian.
Don't get no dicks in your ass.
I think the ending still the same. Oh
so, so he shit. Whoa. So then I go,
don't worry about it.
I'll talk about the biggest loser because
I was obsessed about the biggest loser
and I was like, where can we use it? Ron?
One of the biggest loser because the
girl was due and the girl's like,
we've started talking about, and
I was like, I go, first of all,
Bob and Gillian are beasts because
I've worked out in Bob Spin,
classic crunch La and I go,
he said one of the greatest
things when in a workout,
I remember again I was like 220 pounds
and getting ready to go home for
Thanksgiving and I'm doing
spin class and he says,
I want you to stay out of the saddle,
stand on the salmon for Thanksgiving.
You're going to see
people you grew up with.
Do you want them to look at you and go God
I wish I fucked him. And I'm like, yes,
yes.
And I'm pedaling and pedaling and then,
but I didn't say pug during the thing.
And then the girl goes
and how'd you say that?
Wished that they had been with you.
They want them to look,
really think your life is better.
It was like a long rant cause
then cause then I ended up, I go,
the only thing that bummed me out was
he's gay. So then the whole time she goes,
hold on, Bob is not gay. And I
was like, no, Bob's really gay.
Like definitely you were allowed to say
no, she no, she just didn't know Bob.
The guy she's modeled her
life after is a homosexual.
She had no idea was Bob,
by the way.
Bob and Gillian are the host of this show.
As Bob's totally gave me.
I've never watched the show, so I'm
just, yeah, Bob. Bob is out. Oh yeah.
But she doesn't know. He's not out.
Like you didn't come onto like Andrew,
you know, like whatever talk show
and go. So I was, I'm really gay,
but like not that he would
see like Anderson Cooper out
as anthem, Suku Brown. I
think he's on time. He's gay.
I never thought he was gay and he was
heroic. I have no problem with gay,
but he seems gay. It seems like
a very nice game man. Yeah,
he's definitely pretty lips.
He's Devon Anderson.
Cooper's definitely seems
like it. No he didn't. No, he
is. But I like the guy. Yeah.
I have nothing wrong with him. Be for a
lot of people. That's a huge issue though.
Oh yeah. That's all America. That's
a bummer of an issue, man. I'm like,
what do you give a fuck? Why? Who
Do you, why do you care to farmer?
Some dudes fuck fat chicks that Tom
Breau Kroll is one of those people.
Do you ever think so? It's just cause
it's competition and he's old school.
He's like,
we are coming up behind me and
the ratings making me nervous.
He's got old school gates.
There's moe decker,
[inaudible] cock word of mouth her.
I lived around gay kids
or gay people rather.
I lived around a lot of gay
people when I was growing up.
I got just really to it.
Yeah.
I lived in San Francisco from seven to
11 so the whole time we were constantly
around gay people.
The only time was ever weird was when
some dude whistled at my stepdad was like,
Whoa, that's really, yeah,
that was fucked up. I was like,
that's not just not just like rude,
like guys walking with his son and
you're whistling at them and go,
he made like a like one
of those and I was like,
oh this is the creepiest fucking thing
ever being seven years old and have
somebody do that.
But that's just the Douche bag.
That guy could have been a guy
he could, you know. But it's true
guy rather. He's the same guy working
the sledgehammer that sees the growing
or the over the aggressive,
a lesbian trying to pick up
lemon. If you ever say no,
no, no, fuck that.
I'm talking about the [inaudible] woman
lesbian that walks up to me and say shit
to me at a gay bar.
I live with two lesbians in New
York for a long time and man you,
and we'd go out to their bars cause they
wanted to go there and we'd go and hang
out and have beers and then there'll be
that check to just roll up on me. Like,
what are you doing here? And you're
like, come on, I'm just hanging out.
What are you doing here? No one wants
you here and you'd be like, ugh.
And then my friends would be like,
he's with us. He's our roommate,
and always wanted to be like,
bitch,
I'm the guy that turned you
into the girl you are today.
Don't ever fucking forget that.
Let me get you a drink. Wow. Some pent
hostility that Bert Kreischer. Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait. Let's go. Can we go back
for a second about our brain? Sure. Okay.
Because,
so you give me a buck,
gave it to you and I forgot I gave it
to you and I offered to give it to you
again today and I took it because
this is what you're telling me,
that you had tweeted about some crazy
dreams. I didn't hear them. Okay.
Not even crazy dreams we're talking about.
Does anyone know what a real
fucking lucid dream is? Okay.
A lucid dream for anyone that's
not listening. In my opinion,
this is what these pills did to me. Okay?
It's a dream. When the middle you go,
Oh fuck, I'm dreaming. We can do anything
I fucking want. Okay. Now it is good at.
So I had a dream one time,
I was going in to do an important
TV thing and I was nervous about it.
And so I took, I was taking Alpha
brain and in the dream I went in,
I did it and I did it wrong and it, but
it was so fucking real. It was so real.
I could taste it. And I was
depressed in the middle of a dream,
depressed that I fucked this up.
And then I got in the elevator to leave
and I saw that I was wearing, um, uh,
highlight a neon red Casa workout pants
with a matching needs. I cousin Neon,
a Bandana and no shirt. And I was like,
okay, this is clearly a fucking dream.
But then I realized
yourself dressed shirtless with
a bandanna on to realize, but
I realize it's a dream. And then I
went, that's how you realized it.
It was so fucking real spin.
Your cradle cradle.
Imagine,
imagine just off the fucking interview
where it's like everything you never
wanted to say came out right
and you handled everything
wrong. And I went, okay.
So I wake up, I'm freaked out
and I'm like, and I'm like, okay,
that's how not to do that.
I just problem solved the day.
I'm not concerned because I know not
to say cause I know how that goes.
Now I know know what to say. So then,
so then the next night, and no bite,
mind you every night,
my wife's telling me you
got to stop taking these
fucking awful brains cause I'm
on fire.
I'm like 10 o'clock at night and I'm
still talking about these ideas like I'm
fucking,
they really woke me up.
They go to bed the next night
I'm in the middle of a dream,
I'm doing a photo shoot and the
dream on wheelchair. And I go, I go,
what the fuck am I doing? Almost you're
doing a photo shoot. This is a dream.
I can do anything I
fucking want right now.
And I literally say everywhere we go guys,
I'm going to wrap this a dream.
And they go, Huh? And I walk
out and I, well I'm will sure.
And I fly up La Cienega right
now, fly, fly. I just go, fuck it.
I can fly and I start flying and I go,
this is fucking awesome. Now mind you,
it's also dream. So I got lost in
the hills. So I was like, fuck,
where the fuck am I? Like no, this is
real. So I don't know where the fuck I am.
And I ended up my buddy Lorenzo's
house and I was like, I was like,
I want to say I wanna see my girls, let's
go to my house. And he's like, okay.
And then, you know, in, in dreams and
they just transformed other things.
But every one of my dreams
has been more insane.
And the fact that you can interact inside
them fucking full lips me out to the
point where I was like,
I gotta hop off him cause I need some
rest because I'm going into dreams.
Fucking problems solving shit.
This shit going on in your brain
that use dream about that night.
I'm going in with the ability
to work on in my sleep.
I fucking love these things.
Wow. John Moore, one of my
good friends who, uh, who's,
uh, was one of the writers, uh, to
the, to the Chine roast was like,
he had heard about some of dreams.
You said,
I got to get these fucking
things and then started tweeting,
like hitting you retweeted
one of his things. But man,
these things are fucking awesome.
That's the biggest effect
for me is the dreams.
The way I said it is like a normal
lucid dream to me is like a bubble,
like a children's bubble.
Like it's so fragile. Yeah.
By the time you realize you
have it in your hand, it's gone.
Like every time I've ever had a
lucid dream before I would have them.
And then right in the middle of that I
realized I was dreaming and then boom,
I'd wake up. Right. But in these,
instead of being made out of a bubble,
it's made out of a dodge ball that dodge,
you can just punch it and
fucking move it around.
You just wake up in a dream and
you go, oh, I'm going to dream.
And you just keep going in the dream. It's
very strange. Last night I was testing
a plywood wakeboards for the CIA
and Weeki Wachee and I was like,
I was like fucking totally right.
I saw this video that was the closest
of what I love to drink about,
which is flying.
Yeah.
I think a lot of you all have
that dream about flying around.
Like you were saying,
there's this thing called a body
with these body pair of shoots.
Have you seen this video, Joe? It's uh,
there's this thing called the need for
speed and mountain carving and it's these
guys that have these parachutes attached
to their bodies and they just fly
around these mountains like just
flying over trees and it's, it's crazy.
Wow.
Look at this shit
as soon as I can get it to is
this, is this, is this the guy?
But they got to jump up a mountain,
right hunt.
I think what it uses that uses
the air, uh, like they've done
it here in Calabasas also.
I've seen these people with
these parachutes is just
uses like the air or the
heat of the air or something like
that. But it's a, it's on Vimeo.
It's called the need for speed
mountain carbon checkout.
It will freak you the fuck out.
Like it's, it's terrifying. Uh,
when you see this shit, Oh yeah,
I've seen this, I saw this. Yeah.
This does look really scared.
But these guys also die very often.
Do they like a lot of,
lot,
like more than dude's roller blade?
It seems like it's,
it seems like it's so close that that
like it's just takes one little small
little mistake to fucking die.
You're talking too loud.
You get your mouth like right on that
thing and it gets like way elevated this,
they're like squirrel. Yeah. But
those things are dangerous as fuck.
They're really dangerous.
We did something with someone who was
doing shark diving thing. By the way.
I'm going to do shark dive and
Rachael Ray and a couple of weeks.
What are you trying to die with? Rachael
Ray show with Rachael Ray. Man, Mexico.
Two days. Let me tell you something,
and this is like, don't, nevermind.
Don't repeat this.
That what I was gonna say.
Just don't ever want to tweet Rachael Ray,
that was talking about on your podcast,
but he's very private,
but we just stayed up late,
too late, got hammered.
The trolls are in motion calls down,
set up a buffet, like just fucking,
I had never had more fun with someone.
Like are you in love with Rachel Ray?
A little. Not In love. I could if
she was a man. I have a man crush.
If she was a dude, she'd be your
bestie. Oh, she was my dude. Oh,
we'd be hanging out in my man cave
all the time. Wow. That's really fun.
She's a lot of fun.
She's really cool.
More grounded than anyone and this is the
only reason I say she's grounded is a,
some people ordered some wine to a
room and I've dealt with a lot of,
I don't know how rich he is,
but I'm assuming she's wealthy.
I've go around a lot of
people in sometimes when the
bill comes a and everyone
expects them to sign it, they just
sign it and she looked at, it was like,
who ordered a $350 bottle of wine?
And then they were like, she was like,
where is it? I'm going to definitely
have a glass of that. She goes,
this isn't a $350 bottle of wine.
There's a least at most a 70
of wine from room service.
Send someone up to talk to me about a 350
and I was like, whoa. I was like, man,
she's a real motherfucker.
That Shit my wife does.
So somebody tried to
fuck her over someone.
They sent extra shit up to her room and
she was like, this isn't a $350 yeah,
not at all. I never took him
off. Was this fucking Mexico?
Oh, in Mexico they got crafty.
San Miguel de Allende dude.
What is it like traveling through fucking
Mexico right now? Oh, I'll tell you,
cause I had a fucking security detail.
What's fucking Edgar meets me piece on
his back, right? Old School, Mexican.
Just sit to the airport at Walcott and
goes, Mr Crutcher. And I was like, yeah.
And he goes, let's go. And he,
that dude followed me everywhere.
I went to the bar to drink by
myself. He sat and watched. Really,
he slept outside of my room like let us
outside my room cause he was just like,
it's, it's, you know, it's also
Rachel's production in there.
They're not going to cut
corners on safety, you know,
and what the fuck kind of feeling
is that I got a picture of him.
I'm sure I tweeted it,
but fucking real dude followed me
everywhere to the point that when we went,
I had to go back to their board is
like an hour drive hour drives a little
sketchy in Mexico and we drove
back. He drove with me. I check in,
I checked my bag in and I go,
all right,
a Greg him like a hundred bucks cause
he never left my side. I go, thank you.
Grazia is, he spoke no English and he
goes, um, he goes, no, no, no. A key,
a key and went no, no, no. I'm
just checking in now. He goes, Aki,
Aki until [inaudible] or
what? Our airplane, whatever,
until you get on the airplane,
I'm not leaving. So he waited,
watch me go through security and then
sat there in case I had a problem.
I was fucking awesome.
And Rachel had one too,
but his was much earlier
and much better looking.
Herzer better looking guy
was a fucking stored. Yeah.
Like I'd like to get uncomfortable
around. No, she had hit,
she hit him and she had this black dude
too who is from America that she brought
just extra Eddie. Do you
think they tag team? No,
but I so badly wanted to
get drunk with her and go,
let's make our security details bite
like a fuel and make them fight and let's
just go to a room and then I'd make
them fight and I fight out in the out.
Teach them to teach us how to pistol whip
somebody want something fun in Mexico?
Yeah,
Dude.
So will you terrified we ever able
to relax? No, it was totally tear.
I was totally relaxed and I was
totally not terrified at all. Yeah.
Because although even though you
have all the security everywhere,
the second you have a security guy,
you get brave and you're like,
I can do whatever the fuck I want.
Really know there's like egg or where
do we get some tee shirts? He goes, AH,
north side, north side here, a key. So
we just stayed at this bar and drank.
He just watched me drank the whole
fucking night and I sent and then it kept
mixing up Kiddos and tns. So like I
would want to see, I wanted to say,
do you want a cigar?
But instead I just looked at him like,
do you have a fucking cigar? And
he was like, no, no, no sample.
But who's awesome. It was really
cool. That's a big mistake. Yeah.
It turns you from a nice guy
too. A douchebag. Yeah. And then,
but I realized at the end of the
night when I said it again and I said,
do you want to go to bed with me? And then
I said, you have to go to bed with me.
It's a joke. I missed that joke. I'm not
good on Mexican material.
Did you see anything fucked up
while you were there at all? Any,
any gun fire shit?
Any cars pulled over the side of the
road with tanks or anything crazy? No,
it was pretty,
it was a really fucking laid back.
They say if you're in parts of Mexico,
it's like really safe.
It's border to border town
and it's just fucking,
but being an ignorant American, I just
assumed that the whole country is fucked.
It's like meanwhile,
if you came to America and you,
if you were an alien and you
landed in Detroit at a nowhere,
this is the first place she landed
a straight shot from Alpha Centauri,
right to Detroit. You would be convinced
that the Holocaust has already happened.
There's bears roaming the streets
of Detroit. They've had bears.
They'd take photos of bears in residential
neighborhoods because no one lives
there anymore and it's just the
craziest fucking city of all time.
50% can't read be literacy or,
yeah.
The literacy rate in Detroit
is 47% that was what it,
you can have the two top most dangerous
cities in it to both of them are the two
top ones. Flint is flow.
I can't remember this.
One of the arguments is it so is
Alaska and I think that's just what the
population,
you know the ratio of the population,
the percentage of people
that get murdered.
When I heard this is going to sound
racist, but I'll say it anyway.
I heard that the reason the Alaska so
dangerous is that why people up there?
No Eskimos a slur by the way up
there. Did you know that? Yeah.
Someone just told me that I'm supposed
to say it and you Eskimos like calling it
black eye on nigger. Hey,
that's what it's like.
That's what caught me off guard. I was
like, no, no, that's exactly what it is.
Or now how ridiculous is that? I didn't
know cause I'm calling everyone Eskimos.
Oh Shit.
Walking around like a
time machine and jumped ahead of time
from the 50s into the 2000. I was like,
one of the side effects
from Alpha brand new.
Both learn that that at the same time,
goddamn orientals coming from this guy.
He said orientals once and someone said,
hey man, that's a slur. And I go, Whoa,
how could oriental be a slur?
It's from the Orient.
Yeah. You didn't know that. That's
a big, that's a huge flag. Oh,
orientals and object. Yeah. Yeah.
But the orient is a place.
So being oriental, oriental
person that used to be acceptable.
Yeah. When you could purchase people
to run that make your railroads. Oh
yeah. I think they were like, we
bought all these orientals. Yeah.
We brought them over here. I never
thought these other oriental objects,
like this rug and this hash pipe.
Wow. I never thought of it that way. Wow.
I always thought of it as just being
a designation or, or, or, uh, a,
a past where you're from. You know, what
part of the world, like being a European,
I always thought it was, you
know, or being a westerner.
Yeah, being an oriental,
I really didn't think that
it was an offensive term.
In Canada. They call Indians what
we would call native Americans.
They just call them natives and I was
like, that sounds fucking aggressive.
That's so aggressive on
these fucking natives.
There's water.
The idea is crazy really,
that human beings have only been on
this continent for a couple of thousand
years now and over the last
couple hundred, I mean,
could you imagine taking a look in any
other part of the world and take a look
at it from 500 years ago,
600 years ago, and you know,
there'd still be people
there 600 years ago here.
Fucking no horses, man.
There was no witnesses. Yeah.
American Indians didn't have horses.
They didn't get the horses until the
Europeans came over here. They do.
They were so, they were complete
nomads. They were running down deer.
They would do what's
called persistence hunting,
where they would run down dear until the
deer died of exhaustion and they were
most of the time too tired to even eat.
And so the,
the whole village would eat mean.
It'd be like close to death.
They would be close to death to
kill a steer. Are you shitting out?
Was of a common way of hunting back then
and then they found the horse when the
Europeans came here.
That was easy.
That was the problem with
when the Europeans came here,
the people who are living here at
the time because of their, their,
their folk lore and you know,
I believe it's the ancients,
they thought that the people on horses
were gods. They thought this is,
this is a god,
like someone riding an animal.
Like they had never seen that before ever.
It is bizarre because you and Collin,
this is a fucking,
now I'm doing a podcast
fan of [inaudible],
but you and Kat Callan had talked about
that one time and I have been obsessed
with the concepts that we can,
we have dominion over these fucking
animals that are so much bigger than us.
It would,
you would think if you're a fucking
native American Indian and you see this
Spaniard with the mustache
and the steel hat,
it goes up like this carrying buckets
of gold on a stallion. Just, yeah,
it's impressive.
Well,
what's going on is that the whole rest
of the world was doing agriculture but in
hunt in, but in North America, people were
hunting and gathering. You know, it was,
it was a completely different group of
humans who was all the people that came
down from the Bering Strait from Siberia.
That's where the humans were,
that that's all the American Indians.
You know,
they figured that out because some guy
was convinced that the Mormon books were
true and that Joseph Smith had told the
truth and Joseph Smith had said that
the,
what the American Indians were with the
last lost tribe of Jesus and that they
had come to America with the last words
of Jesus and were written on these
golden scrolls and only he
can read them all the shed.
And so this guy in trying to prove that
it was true actually did like a DNA test
on native Americans and
found out that they're Asian,
that they come from Siberia,
come from the connection or
weight. Imagine I would love to
foster those people just walked man.
And they say they have the same culture
for thousands of years because when they
got here,
there was no civilization here before
because the entire fucking continent was
covered in ice. We don't even, we can't
even wrap our head around that. Like for,
for thousands and thousands of years,
there was nothing here.
There was just melted ice and
a few fucking weird, you know,
annual type people wandering around
killing things of bows and arrows,
putting nuts, man, I, you
said something that I,
that I'm going to, hopefully
this will make sense, but,
so the Indians did not know how to
bring the corn closer to their house.
They just were like, well,
the corner over there.
Well, I don't know about that. I don't
know. They probably know Agora. Well,
and you know, and when they first came
down there certainly wasn't, but I, it's,
I dunno whether or not Indians
established their own agriculture.
Nobody than they supposedly, oh, no,
no, no. It was, it was the tobacco it,
but it was the idea that the Americans
or the rather the original settlers
taught the American Indians, the native
Americans had to plant their corn.
Wasn't that,
I wouldn't think so. I think we
could have known and here's why.
Here's the only reason I agree or I hear
that and I go, who should fucking know?
That's something we should know.
Like Charlie Brown probably taught us that
politician guy when I was a
while ago and he was very racist,
older,
um,
like from the south and he
was slamming like fucking, uh,
the people of that,
the,
the native people of South America.
He was like,
these motherfuckers couldn't even
use a wheel and it cause apparently.
Yeah. And I was like, whoa.
And I was like, shut up.
And I just thought he was just being
racist. It was fun to listen to.
But apparently it was true when
the Spaniards came over there,
like that toy you give your children
will use it to move fucking hall shit.
I was like,
fuck.
Well,
you know what's even more incredible,
what this was all post when they had
built those pyramids. So all this,
you know,
that's thousands of years ago.
So they built the pyramids and use
the fucking wheel. Well, we don't,
we don't have a goddamn clue as how they
built Cheech needs a or any of those
places. But they built them
essentially without any horses
that, without, you know,
and then,
but I didn't even machines and these,
these fucking people built these
incredible stone structures in the jungle.
You know,
I don't know how the fuck they did it.
The obviously did figure out how to do it.
That's a fucking reality show. It's
amazing. Can you make a pyramid
now using horses? No. Horses
the loud. If you wait,
if we catch you bringing in a horse on
the plane, you're, you're off the show.
Yeah. You, uh, listen
to the podcast that we have with Graham
Hancock. Did you listen to that one? Yeah,
the, he's on the money. I think he's dead
on their money. I think that there was a,
there was a whole other
advanced civilization a long
time ago and they got wiped
to fuck out. Well, after you're talking
about aliens, well he didn't, he,
I don't think he had a really specific,
yeah,
nobody that night right after I
saw that I saw a thing on, um, on,
he was on history channel about 80 yards.
Yeah.
And they were talking about how the, how
the fucking aliens, it's all the aliens.
And I was like, and then I think I
mixed the two and then I make that up.
Um, and the, uh, the guy
with a British accent,
Giorgio sucralose. Who Guy who was a, no,
Graham Hancock has a guy with a
British accent. Giorgio sucralose is,
the guy was from ancient aliens. We had
him on the podcast too. Gray Heron. Yeah.
He's an interesting cat.
He believes everything is alien.
It's how long until you're
tired of talking to people?
I don't,
I don't have a problem with it,
but when are you going to tap out and be
like, I think I've talked to everyone.
I want to talk to him. Well, nothing.
Never because I'm talking to you again.
You know, it's like I think all
I know I get two more visits and
you're gonna be like, dude, Dunkin says
that every time it comes over, man.
I don't know if family thing
you talked about, man, go,
don't worry about it, dude.
Let's just fucking riff.
Come on. It's taught you,
you're always going to have a look.
You're not going to stop thinking, man.
You're not going to stop. You're
not going to stop experiencing life.
You're not going to
stop having revelations.
You're not going to stop having stories.
You know?
It's crazy.
You've had training in doing podcasts
before we even did started this podcast
because I don't know how many times,
like after a show or something,
we would all go eat.
It's always going to go eat with like
everybody that were hanging around with
and we would sit there for hours
and did the same thing as a podcast.
But without fucking recording.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
We had some classic conversations with
you and me and Eddie Bravo and you know
every comedian are Rhea,
Joey [inaudible].
And let me tell you the best
thing about this podcast is,
is what I'm waiting for a fucking
Falcon. The land on your arm, dude.
By the way, if you want to make your own
Falcon risk thing just used pineapple.
I had been making Falcon Risks
Cause we've been juicing and
we just got a juicer. Say,
well you were going to say,
we're going to say I fucking got
obsessed with Eddie Bravo one night.
Really just obsessed.
It's like the window.
You guys were talking about him making,
creating a move and then some guy
moot use that move for the first time.
That was when a guy caught the
first twister in the UFC. Right.
And then I'll really create the move.
He just invented a whole lot of setups
for it and became a master at it and
really good at teaching it.
Right.
And then I started following them on
Twitter and then I was like, Eh, I do.
He just is so much more diversity
human being. Then anyway,
I start researching them and I'm like,
well he's got 10th planet.
He does his own Jujitsu. He teaches
Jujitsu, he's written books about it.
He's in a band. He's, I go out,
he seems a lot more diverse than
the majority of people out there.
So then I just started reading all his
Wikipedia, watching all these videos,
and then I'm like, okay, this is getting
borderline gay. I go, there's no way,
any problems watching my shit.
He's an interesting dude.
I never met a guy like Eddie Bravo.
Fascinating guy.
He's the guy who got me to smoke weed.
That's what I was like. I was like,
how did that
Doug Benson smoked,
didn't smoke weed until he was like 30
also, look man, if you, if you don't know,
and one of the reasons why a
lot of people don't like pot,
it's cause they're not smoking pot.
You know one of the reasons why they're
worried about other people doing it
because they're scared they're going to
like it themselves and they're scared
about doing it. It's like the same thing
about doing scare them up being a loser.
That's what you're scared about.
You not scared. I'm telling you,
it's not going to make
you a goddamn loser.
I thought it did and a lot of you do too.
It's a trick. Had been fooled. It's a,
it's a very fabulous tool for the mind
and in 45 days we are all going to get
rid of our local pot shops because Obama
is destroying us all and we're all going
to die. Are you shitting me? Yeah, they,
he phrases
it so eloquently like a gay woman
because of I was destroying us.
A woman, a gay woman. That's a gay man.
Hands flap out like slipper drawing
us all and we're all gonna die.
Now you said that you couldn't have
said that gay anti Gracie. That was such
a way that, yeah. Did you hear
Nancy Grace Park it on the air
since she was on Tmz.
We'll look fat people for the last seen
her nipple and she farted in a month.
Whatever you're doing Nancy Grace and
now I'm on your team. I want to see more.
I want to see your ass hole. I want to
see fucking everything. Nancy Grace Porn.
Who Do you want to see
your fuck? No, no, no.
The guy from the Michael Jackson trial,
the doctor. I want to see him back up.
Those two days. That'd be off.
She wants the forbidden fruit.
You big fucking the African American.
Definitely.
It's important guys. She's going
to do four guys. Well, the first,
first one, she's just got to
do one guy up. Just one. One
more group brother. What?
Hardcore gangster dude
with tattoos on his face.
And then I'd love to see Fox
morning run a train on her.
Just fucking with this other chick.
Fox morning news through
Hank Williams under the bus.
I went Dallas rain or rain on her back.
You know what I'm talking about?
It Neil, a local guy, local weatherman,
but his name's Dallas rain
and he's a weatherman.
Well that's better than Brent
coming. He's the guy who got who? Uh,
they found a dead guy next to him
naked in a bathtub with no water. Okay.
Frame was Cummings.
They found a dead guy next to him and
you don't know this and it was another
fucking weather guy.
Fred Rogan did it.
Weather guy in Arkansas
or no. Uh, Oklahoma,
I think one of those either Arkansas,
Oklahoma and he was one of these guys
with the crazy fake whether voice,
we've got a high pressure system coming
in for the east. Those guys that,
you know how like some radio Djs do the
same thing that was put on this fucking
fake voice. You're like, who are
you? Because when I'm on the air,
we're on the air and we're back
rolling.
So tell me Bert Kreischer standup comic
since 1,999 what got your started?
Wait, let's get back to you pat.
They, who's they? And was he asleep?
Did he not know?
There's a big guy next to him.
He,
they,
he was at a guy's house and they were
all partying and snort and drugs.
This is the store.
And the dude wakes up in the middle
of the night cause he hears snoring.
Just ridiculous. Snoring goes
downstairs, opens up the bathroom.
There's a dead guy in the bathtub
with a dog collar on next to a snoring
weatherman and they're both naked
and there's no water in the bathtub.
It's awesome.
You got to know that somewhere out there
there's someone that's fucking up way
harder than you.
It's a prospective enhancing the water.
Just all emptied into their assholes.
I don't know. No, probably not.
We were the first words out of your mouth.
You're woken up.
There's a dead guy with a dog collar
on you and you're in a bathtub.
First words out of your mouth.
She don't wake him up.
He sounded does face was purple. Oh,
okay. He's totally dead. He was dead.
He was 68
probably choked on his own vomit. And who
knows? Overdosed when. Oh, so what's your,
you don't
say anything? You can see I give somebody
that's not a fucking party. Get Out.
Fucking shake it off. That's
how you know. Nobody could ever
say shit to that dude.
I mean,
I know you're the king of partying you
so much so that they made that van wilder
movie that movie's based on
you and this is a true story.
A lot of people don't know
this sounds like horse shit,
but they made a fucking movie based
on you being such a party animal.
But you can't fuck with that guy.
If he wants to talk.
I saw who parties hardy bitch.
I party so hard with people.
They die sometimes naked.
They're in a bad dog or that dog collar.
That's how you know you're partying hard,
dude.
You're partnering with winds up
naked with a dog collar on dead.
You know how hard it would
be to get people out for
drinks and mean that homeboy,
I just fell asleep. It
didn't even bother him. He,
you know this is fucking dead and he's
snoring so loud.
He wakes to flog it dude up.
They wake him up and he's like,
can you imagine your store? Who the fuck
is snoring? Man, it's fucking party.
Been over for two hours.
Who's in my house got damaged?
You come wandering downstairs and
that's what you find dead guy with a dog
collar on.
Fucking well let me out and wonder
what they're snorting credible.
The anticodons Oxycontin's apparently
are all the rage. That's what a,
they're having a real real problem
with with kids. I did it recently.
Did you really
retard
cause you're going to pass out backwards.
Trying to go the other way.
I took two hits just to try it out
because she took two and it was very crack
addict.
You take aluminum foil and you put the
pill on top of it and you light it from
underneath so it kind of melts and then
you take a straw and you kind of do it
like you're inhaling the fumes that
it burns from chasing the dragon. Huh?
Chasing the dragon chasing the dragon.
They did it with heroin too.
Why don't you just swallow
the pill? Because I think
you can get more out of it.
Like I think it's a new smoking.
It hits you faster,
I think maybe should as you faster for
sure. Gross people who are addicted are,
can't even wait until the pill digests
and starts to work in your body.
You have to smoke it. It didn't,
it didn't. It fueled a little,
but honestly it was like more like,
I think if I took Nyquil
it would have been better.
You know like or something like that.
It wasn't to me it felt gross.
And like definitely I have a good
thing feeling when I do some drugs.
I'm just like, you know what,
that's just a stupid ass drunk.
And that was totally one of
those stupid ass dreads. Sued.
There was a crazy story that I ran across
yesterday and I put it on the rogue
board and uh, apparently it's
been going around for a while.
There's a dude on vice TV and he,
uh,
he interviewed this chick
and she's on Youtube.
She calls herself neuro soup. Have
you ever heard of this girl? Yeah.
She's the one who had a
video about putting upper
abs right there. Like how
long a trip went? Yeah.
What comedy troupe is she in?
She's not in a comedy troupe at all.
It's a neuro soup is her youtube video
that's on youtube name. So anyway,
this, this dude Hamilton Morris
is this, uh, the like the,
the head psychedelic guy over@vice.com.
You know,
vice.tv or vbs.tv, the vice guide
to Liberia. You know, those,
those crazy travel guides, if
you ever watched those, no.
You are missing out on a chunk of crazy.
These guys are fucking bad ass man. Yeah,
they go everywhere. I mean Thailand,
Thailand and pickup lady boys and
shit. They go, they go to Liberia,
they go to Liberia and they
go to whorehouses in Liberia
where it's like dollar
where it's like sex is like a dollar
and there's no windows to the place.
They're like like oh like you know like
cement huts. Who are these guys do?
They're bad asses and this this guy,
Hamilton Morris is the psychedelic guy
and he writes a all these articles about
psychedelic and he interviews people
and he interviewed this check and this
neuro soup girl and this neuro soup girl,
her name was crystal.
She was living with this guy.
She was a stripper,
a golf stripper in Kansas and she was
living with this guy who was like the
number one LSD and MDM,
a dealer in the area and
this guy had a missile silo.
He bought a missile silo,
one of those and he bought like it got
into like some underground nuclear bunker
type situation. It's fucking place
was radical. It's incredible.
There's long as photos of it online.
If you're looking for good advice.com
it's Hamilton's pharmacopia getting high
on crystal. If you want to just look
for getting high on crystal, k, r, y, s,
t, l, e, look for that online and
following her on Twitter. Yeah, whatever.
So anyway, this girl, um, she,
she hooks up with this dude and she
stopped stripping and becomes this crazy
psychedelic head.
Like she's doing everything under the
fucking sun every day of the week.
She's just one day she's doing acid.
The next day she's doing DMT.
And these guys had DMT hooked up to ivs.
They had it to up to ivs when they
were doing liquid DMT and they had,
they were regulating it on the ivy.
So they were surfing the DMT dimension of,
they were constantly getting it brought
in their body and who knows what the
fuck they did to their heads. But one,
one of the guys started going crazy,
her boyfriend and when her boyfriend
decided that her, his partner was, uh,
was doing bad things or was
going to fuck them over,
it was going to get him arrested.
So he goes to the DEA.
These fucking guys have a
missile silo where they're,
they're dripping DMT into their
veins and homeboy did so much,
he brought himself to the DEA.
So he turns his buddy end to the DEA.
And then, you know, the,
the dude who's the chemist winds up doing
like two life terms or something like
that, you know, he's fucked and they give
him immunity. They give him immunity.
So this is how our DEA ruts
just fucking got, yeah,
this guy who was just his probably just
completely cooked. It's fucking brain.
So he winds up traveling for free.
I mean, he can, he's a free man.
He doesn't have to worry about,
he's not running from the cops.
He winds up traveling the whole country
while this is buddy is doing two life
terms with this girl
and all over the place.
They're just doing insane drugs at every
stop along the way until they get back
and she's trying to get away from him.
She hooks up with another dude and the
other dude is telling her like, hey,
you know, we've got to turn this guy in
like he's crazy, he's going to kill us.
So they go to the Dea and
the DEA tells the guy, hey,
you're fucking girlfriend.
And her new boyfriend just came and
visited us and they told us everything,
you fucking dummy, you better deal
with that. So this fucking crazy man.
It's crazy dealer guy that she,
you know, the original guy,
he takes them and locks them in a hotel
room and dopes then and ties this dude
up to a chair and it administers
drugs into his dick and his balls with
injections.
And he did it for a week.
It is the craziest story of just excess
and chaos and just a complete insanity.
Just chemical induced
complete and Saturday.
It's not like homeboy was probably crazy
to begin with back when he was selling
drugs out of a missile silo. But, but
at the end he was guns Ville again.
He was,
it was gone.
I'm sure there's going to make it
sound like I'm so lost in the story.
How did you hear about
this advice when a jerk,
penis.com
I'll just let that set.
There was a message board all about about
inserting drugs into your penis. No. Uh,
somebody sends me on Twitter I think. I'm
pretty sure we're, we're, can I see this?
Like I said, it's on vice.com
is this spice Dotcom,
is this like 100% accurate like web,
like story and everything?
Cause this seems so ridiculous now.
It's all documented. It's all doctors.
I looked the whole thing up. It's a huge
article. If you read the article online,
it is, let me, let me go to
it. I think it's like 10 pages.
It's a really big and very deep.
Seven pages. A very detailed article,
but it all happened van. It's a pretty
famous story. Isn't it weird though,
when you hear things like this and
you're like, nowadays you're like,
this has to be fake.
Like even when John know what you're
talking about because this doesn't seem
fake at all of them.
Tell him that fake actually somebody
kidnap somebody and the inserts fucking
drugs into their penis and
ask you to consider who
you're talking about. The Guy,
the guy,
the guy that did it is a guy that had
already turned on somebody and so he'd had
those nights of him on drugs.
That's an awesome story.
I got fucking turned on
and I go fucking crazy.
And then they come to him and tell him
and that his wife's not only fucking some
other dude, but he turned
them on also. I don't know.
That's not too far out of the spectrum.
It's just weird that like some
of these stories nowadays,
it just seems so far fetched and amazing.
But this isn't far fetched at all.
This is this too to me. I know what you're
saying, but this to me seems pretty, uh,
pretty normal. Normal. Yeah.
When people start selling drugs,
this guy was a dealing
kilos of Crystalyn Mtma.
He was just traveling across the country
selling MDM and they were doing it
constantly.
Put that in perspective.
Probably could for someone
that's never done DMT, DMT,
the BMA kilos Mtma is
ecstasy. For. You don't know.
It's the pure stuff. And that's
what I heard. And what it is, is a,
you know what it is? It's incredible.
It feels awesome, but God damn,
it takes a toll on your brain. Woo.
The next day. I've never felt dumb,
and I've heard that if you get really
good stuff, it doesn't do that.
But I call horse shit. It does it.
There's a guy in college who, uh,
who used to do a lot of ecstasy.
I wish I could remember this kid's name.
Everyone that went to college with me,
I'll know exactly what I'm talking about.
Little short hair with blonde hair.
It looked like a surfer.
I look like mark Ahca Lupo the surfer,
and then towards the end of college,
like he used to have the
saying for cigarettes borrowed.
Bariums bariums he called
cigarettes. Baron. Nerium. Yeah.
But then we just realized he was so
fucked up that he was trying to say Hemi.
There was like a French cigarette,
but it was, that was what he smoked.
But he just came out of
his mouth. [inaudible] I
started going on him and man,
I died to see what that
kid looks like now.
People that were really fucked up and go
on Facebook to ecstasy really has taken
a lot of people's brains.
I've met many people that I know do a lot
of ecstasy and they wind up completely
fallen apart. It's so bad for you. I mean,
I would venture to say that
as a father of two I will,
I will make the cover off statement and
my children, all drugs are bad for you.
Don't do any of them because it would
be nice to get to a Dane Cook place in
life where you've never
done fucking anything.
What are you even talking
about it like no, no,
but I mean just to be like to be
just sitting in bed and going on.
I don't have to worry about
fucking inhaling fucking
glade as a child and wonder
what that did to my lungs or, or you
know, like cocaine or acid or ecstasy.
Like when I'm having a panic attack in
the middle of the night and I'm like,
great, I did this to myself.
Sometimes I feel that way. I go,
if I had never done anything with any
of this shit, be around, you know,
I would love to tell me to tell my
kids that, you know, be healthy.
I'm sure you tell your kids the same
thing. Yeah. And most certainly,
but I just want to be real clear with
them about what is legal and or rather
what is dangerous and what is not
and what simply illegal, right?
There's some reasons why things are
illegal that don't make any sense at all.
And it's a good lesson.
It's a good lesson that the world is
not structured correctly and you have to
know that and always mind your p's and
q's and everything is not as it seems to
be because there's a whole,
the system that we're operating under is
fucking crazy. It's ridiculously flawed.
And so I would make sure that
before I got into anything, I would,
I would let them know that.
So don't always believe what you hear.
And then here's what's dangerous. Here's
what's addictive. Here's what's what's,
you know, what's going to get
you locked up in jail? You know,
here's what's actually legal. Here's,
you know, here's what's, you know,
legal and safe. Here's what's legal and
not so safe. You know? And by the way,
don't do anything by
yourself. Make sure, you know,
you know what the fuck you're doing.
Do it with people that you trust and
only hang around people that you trust.
You know, I thought, I find that people
that hang around with people
that they don't trust,
and it's really because they didn't have
good relationships with their parents.
You know,
I,
I'm going to try to have the best possible
relationship as a friend with my kids
as possible so that they'd
never feel like they can talk.
They can't talk to me about something and
I want to talk to him about every step
along the way of their life,
you know?
And I think that's what
you're supposed to do. Yeah.
The idea of drug scare the shit out of me,
man.
The idea of math or something like that,
but it was hot. I'm scared about
like Oxycontin, meth, coke, coke.
I don't want my daughters to get around
that wall that stops the mushrooms even
need like I've had,
I've had friends,
I'm sure I've said this a million times,
but I've,
I've done mushrooms and I've always had
great experiences except at night when I
see the shadow people. But I've
never, like I, I would probably,
we'll do them again as an adult because
I think I've done all the exploring.
I want to do,
like I,
I tried to do them one one night
we were doing at Jamison tour,
there's a meet a bunch of comics and um,
we admonish mushrooms and I think we each
took like a couple of caps and then I
went on stage, I think I told you this
and then I fucking lost my shit on stage.
But then I started freaking her on
mushrooms onstage at the Dallas Improv and
all I could see as the candles in
the back on. And I'm like, Oh fuck.
And then I started thinking
I can't get off the grid.
Like I am responsible for people
right now. Like, I am the fucking,
and I'm not the kind of brain that can
just dip into it and dip out of it.
Like I'm responsible for humans.
Like what if I fucked up?
What if I fucked up tonight?
And then I just was, I was cool.
I fucking turned it around and it
was fine and had a great night.
But that's not the horror story,
but that's a real moment.
You know that that thought
as a father that's,
so that's where things get really strange.
You know,
you think of these little helpless
children that they're looking out for you.
Then again,
you need the only one is not for me to
see have a fun party night at a piano bar
or somewhere in Dallas, but to,
for me to like just read me a book.
That's all we want. You know,
and you just, and then that,
then that grounds you and you're like,
all right,
that's where I'm at right now in life.
I just need to get through tonight,
drink myself out of this and fucking get
to the other side myself out of this.
I've done that so many times to move.
I'll do that and amp system and a couple
of weeks. Drink yourself in a dark,
dense drink. Fucking yet black yourself
out. Fucking worse than it is on the stone
now how much do you say,
what would you,
what would you say your percentage of
alcohol intake is versus marijuana intake
gap way, way, way more. We'd like give
me a percentage. You drink every day? No.
Like we're at dinner. Do you have
like a glass of wine or anything?
I sometimes do, but not every
day. No. I find myself not, not,
I've been drinking a lot more
lately, but it's been like, no,
I'll have wine with dinner
or I'll have like a drink,
but not drinking all night long.
Right, right, right, right.
Well that's certainly not good for you.
But they've,
they've done studies that have said,
you know, whether or not this is true,
they've said that,
you know,
having a couple glasses of wine
a day is actually good for you.
Yeah. Yeah. I've heard to drink a beer
every day or drink a glass of whiskey.
Really for Ya.
You know what it would do for you as far
as relaxing you and I think, you know,
it's good.
It's good to enjoy your time.
It's obviously not good to take a poison
into your body, but if that poison,
that alcohol poison, you know,
if it's easily processed,
which alcohol basically is,
you know,
especially like one beer for the
average liver, it's no big deal.
You too. I want to look at
both. You just accidental.
It's not much work for it,
you know?
And so it's a one beer can
be processed pretty easily,
but when you start getting into high,
high numbers and then it gets
toxic and then you're, you know,
and then you're dealing with, you know,
all, you're poisoning your fucking body.
When you wake up from a hangover,
it's, that's not an accident.
You, you're, you're, you're
hurt. Sometimes you're like,
I didn't mean for that to happen.
You hurt yourself
for the booze, but you can have
a little, not, not do that.
That doesn't have to happen.
Just gotta to know what the fuck you're
limits are man. Drink a lot of water too.
That's the, someone told me
they were like, you should
put ice in your beer. I do.
You used to do at beer, water, beer, water
or drink, water, drink, water, drink.
Like that was what I had to
do when they go out. You know,
I respect the fuck out of someone who
can hold their booze. Oh, thank you.
I can hold my to hold your booze.
I get,
when we calculated the
last time you were here,
you drink nine beers over the course
of two hours. Those are nothing.
Here's the problem. Here's
where it gets tricky is, um,
I also, you can't ever tell if I'm drunk.
I'm like, no one can tell if I'm drunk.
Like maybe you can. That's great.
But like Mike Mow, my wife, perfect.
We'll be in the middle of a fight and
all of sudden she'd be like, hold on.
Are you fucking drunk? And I'd
be like, yeah. So I'd be like,
you've been fucking drunk. Does, does
it? No, you don't mean any of this.
And I'm like, well, you're still
real retribution, whatever for,
I think it just confuses people
when they look at you. They're just,
they just see beards and stuff,
so they don't think you're drunk,
but look at you with what does
that lesbian dealing with a beard.
That's the confusing part. That's a
little late. On the flip side though,
people also think I'm drunk when I'm
not. Oh right. Like what? Like when I'm,
when I'm on state,
whenever I'm on stage I'll,
if I'll bring up your on stage of me,
you know,
and I'll be like first beer of the night
and everyone's like, whatever. Right.
I was like, no, I'm okay. I guess.
I guess maybe it's just being fat and
they're like, he's been wrong. Hold on.
Well they think you're just telling a joke
to, you know, instead of a declaration,
which isn't funny. If you had had
30 already, then it would be Kinda,
Kinda cute pair of the night.
Yeah. I never come off drunk,
but people always think I'm high
always and whatnot. Yeah. Yeah.
Like UFC, he's like, dude, Rogan's blues
tonight. No, never, never do the FCI.
How was the UFC and a huge,
crazy fucking awesome.
What's serious fights man, Frankie Edgar
and gray Maynard. Did you see it now?
No, but I tweeted that you said it
was going to be fucking sick. Who
was the nuttiest rematch ever?
The first fight that gray Maynard
won the first fight by decision,
but the second fight was a draw and it
was a crazy draw because gray Maynard had
Frankie Edgar badly, badly hurt in the
first round and grain Mainers. A big guy.
Frankie Edgar is one of the rare
guys that fights his weight class.
So he is 155 pounds. That's
really what he weighs. Yeah,
and he's fighting gray Maynard
who's a really fit guy.
He probably is 20 pounds heavier
than that and diets down, you know,
cuts his weight and cuts his water
weight and everybody's like, like yield.
He's sweet,
he's way bigger.
He looks like he's a dangerous dude and
he's a power puncher and he hurt Frankie
Edgar really bad in the first round of
their second fight and like really bad.
Knocked him down like three times.
Look there.
The fight was over on several occasions,
but somehow the Frankie Edgar rebounded.
They came back and won the second round.
It was chaos and then they battled back
and forth to the bitter end and then you
want to be in a draw. Well, this is
the third fight. First round, gray.
Maynard hurts Frankie Edgar a den bad,
walks in with an upper cut.
It looks like he's on the
verge of getting stopped.
Gray Maynard's present for just blast.
And if he catches him a couple of times,
has a badly badly hurt when he gets back
to his corner the second round you're
like, man, this kid might be fucked.
Second round he goes up and just
boxes and moves boxes and moves.
Third round,
same thing,
boxes and moving boxes and then by the
third or fourth round gray Maynard starts
getting desperate. He's like, why
can't hit this fucking kid again?
And he's charging after him and then
they get at it in the fourth round and
Frankie Edgar catches him with a punch
and rocks them and then puts them away.
It was chaos. Really ever. Have,
I seen a guy get hurt that bad in the
first round and then come back to knock
the guy out like that in the fourth round.
The fact that he did it in two fights
that he came back from just devastating
first rounds.
Those first rounds take a lovable,
you get beaten up like that
takes so much out of you,
and this motherfucker is so tough
that he'd just gutted it out,
got through that second round, kept
moving, got through the third round.
They had put it on him and
the fourth was fucking crazy.
Just a wild fight.
Me and the whole place erupted.
People were standing on their feet.
It was just a crazy, crazy fight.
I never find myself being able to
relax, watching MMA. It's hard. I mean,
that's part of the fun
sweating all of a sudden guys,
it's not relaxing when it's an active
viewing sport. Addictive issues.
Yeah. It's fucking when you, when
you find yourself, when you'd like,
when, okay, this is a bad analogy, but
when I was a kid, if I watch people,
kids on TV, I would start air
kissing like, wow, really?
Yeah. My Dad would be like, what the fuck
would you think about the one day someday
you're going to be able to kiss some
money. Yeah, but you nailed it right hand.
Everything's stupid. That could have
been done. I did, but when I watch MMA,
I find myself going like, like twisting
and turning my body, like uploading stuff.
Sometimes I do that.
Like if a guy's not tapping,
if a guy's got something and then
somebody got an arm bar or something,
like I got like, I'll hold my arm, I'll
grab my own arm. I got that. That tap tap.
Come on. Do tap like I've, I've said it
before when guys don't have, I'm like,
come on man. Tap. Just
tap or of the tab. Yeah.
I don't want anybody to
break their God damn arm.
I don't want to see
that fucking bowl photo.
You fucking booze do without
any fucking morning, Joe. I did.
What I posted is,
it's a lesson that we all know,
but some of us need to learn first hand.
You Fuck with the bowl? You
get the horns. A guy in Spain,
a bullfighter got a gore.
Oh,
throughout a horn through his face where
it came out. His eyeball to new one.
It's a new one.
The photo is just fucking amazing.
I was laying in bed like I
can go to sleep. I could wait.
I'm just going to click on this
little link. Joe just posted.
Then I had to like go outside and have
a cigarette and think about eyeballs for
like 10 minutes and be back home.
He lost his eye is the horn
went through his entire face.
It's fucking incredible, man.
That's the problem. The animals man.
You can't fucking tell him to
slow down. Well, it's a bull.
You're there fighting bulls is the
dumbest fucking thing ever telling me.
I got mauled by a bull. You
did? Of course. Yeah. Yeah.
I got mauled by a level.
Of course I did travel network,
but happen. I was just online.
It's online. It's online. I'm burnt.
The concrete or Herbert hurt.
Bert, what was her burn? Her burn.
Aww. I love you. The um, Herbert
was a show I had before birth.
The conqueror is where I take
dangerous manage jobs for a day.
He's fought the MMA,
the Gracies.
Oh, that's right. I thought that was
from birth to conquer from her birth.
And one of the days they call
like you want to be a rodeo clown. And
I was like, I was like, not really.
And then I'll come on, we're going to
the Texas, he'll be a great fucking trip.
And then I go thinking I'll
learn something and they
just tell me to show me how
to put the makeup on and that's it.
And then they just put me in the ring
and they pull a fucking bulldoze.
You can see it, you can see
it so quick. Um, if you go to,
if you type into youtube
hurt Bert Rodeo clown,
it just shows up and you just see my
ribs get broken and I break my foot and
then they go,
what do they say?
Don't go to the wall. And
then automatically I went
right to the fucking wall.
I was like, oh I do. I get
out of here with broken ribs
was crazy. How crazy your life
is really like you're, you're,
you're no joke.
Your and your documentary,
is that going to go through all this
documentary starts this weekend? Yeah.
Starts this weekend in Tempe or Phoenix
at stand up live. If you've been there,
the documentary that you funded with
kickstart funded with kickstarter.com
mainly through this,
through this podcast.
Every listener that I guarantee
every listener if you're listening,
thank you so much for support.
They're all I eat. I texted you,
I think of the day everyone's
international and I know
that I had never been
international so it's do this
podcast. That's awesome. That's sweet.
And your shirts are on
their way and I got shirts,
I've been wearing them to the listeners.
Your shirts are on your way or wife is
sitting there at the post office with
boxes and boxes of shirts and it takes,
she said it takes one minute per
shirt and she has 3000 shirts.
So she's sitting at the post office and
she had just has to give up after a few
hours because she just can't
stand any more per poor feet.
And so then I'm thinking this is why the
post office is going out of business.
Cause she can't even spend money fast
enough by shipping shit without it taking
a fucking minute. His shirt, it takes
forever. And I told her, I was like,
I'll do it. And she's like,
no. Can it take any shorter?
I mean it seems pretty reasonable. You
know what, you should be able to do,
put a name on it.
You'd be able to drop box on it and
then send it across the country. Yeah,
but you should be able to drop off all
her packages that are already with the
address and stuff. Drop it
off and like, all right,
come back in two days and then we'll
give you the bill for it and amend the
minute is probably filling
out the addresses. That's
probably what it is. No, no,
no.
They're already filled out and everything.
It's all about putting a stamp on it.
It takes forever to like weigh.
It takes a minute to put a stamp on
that.
She's got a high volume
of things she's sending.
But imagine if it wasn't for
fucking ups or stuff like that. God,
the world would suck. Well she's
probably going through to save money.
She's probably going through the US
postal system as opposed to going to FedEx
or ups where it would take,
oh,
and I'm saying is the post office look at
your about to go out of business? Very,
very fine. That sounds like a
threat, don't you think terrorist?
Don't you think that is?
I think because of the Patriot Act
they could probably arrest you now.
They probably could. But you see
that? Do you see that happening?
I mean all my bills now are through my
email. Even when I go to the fucking bank,
it sends my receipt to me.
I heard you guys talking about that
when I was in the bathroom putting my
Rogaine on and I thought to myself,
yeah,
but how else are we going to get the
shirts there? We need the boat. Of course.
I can't just email. It can be private
third parties that have more sense like,
Hey, no, you just drop off all your shit
and yeah, that's all you have to do. Yeah.
UPS is so much,
infinitely better than the point of the
towns will never go to the post office.
I, it's totally makes sense
stuff. It saves you money,
but yeah, it'd be like that.
That's unfortunate that needless to say,
the shirts are being shit
that are sent being sent out.
The biggest problem was
because everyone in the second,
you were one on the podcast,
everyone below up, they're like,
I want to fucking dope shirt.
It is a total shit that people
commented on it a bunch of times.
I want it to Texas. I know, I saw
that somebody tweeted like, awesome,
how do you see you have a machine shirt?
I was like, well cause come on. Seriously.
How the fuck you asking that question?
Monkey Todd.
God bless monkeys.
Now you hung out with monkey Todd and
there was photos posted and you are both
not wearing shirts.
I haven't questioned.
Why don't you explain to people
who'd look, he's a fan of the show.
Yeah, he, he, he actually,
he told Bert this whole story about his
life about getting cancer and all this
shit like that and talking about
that. Oh, I might not want you to see
your podcast kind of helped him.
I helped him up with UFC tickets
and sat right next to Ari. Yeah,
he's a really cool guy. Really grounded.
And I hung out with them for the night,
like we not into the night we hang out.
And then he was like, I got that role.
He has a desk squad cat tattooed
on his arm. That's crazy eyes.
He's did the Nancy grace video.
But every time you post photos
you always have your shirt off.
Is this something that you do,
like when you're at a party,
just to explain that Nancy grace video,
you just glossed over what we talked
about on the podcast before, but,
but for purple people are just listening
to this one. Just what did he do?
He pretty much, he calls in shows and one
of the shows he caught it and was TMZ.
Nancy grace was on this show and he
did like, who would you fuck marry,
kill? Uh, with me, Sam Tripoli
and teat Jason Tebow. And uh,
it got on the air and it did it that
the producer director did not pull it
either.
They'd let it run.
And so monkey Todd was just like
continuing like just making it the most
uncomfortable video ever and
fuck you.
And he confused it a lot.
Like he talked a lot,
he taught his method is talking a lot of
jibberish so it's like what the fuck is
he talking about? And then go on, so
would you fuck marry, kill a red band,
same Tripoli and Jason Tebow and and a he.
So he did this and what's crazy is that
Nancy grace was like the first time a
TMZ was like,
like we're going to have real guests now.
We're going to start having yeah,
real guests now.
And that's how they screw it.
But that's how you're going to go
live, man. If you're going to go live,
that's just what you get. You're going
to have Baba buoys once in a while.
I love them.
They make me laugh.
It's hilarious when they get someone
who's like a witness to something and
they'd go deep, deep, deep into it and
then they blah blah blah. Then you go,
oh you motherfucker.
The other side of that though,
and we've heard this a million times,
is when you're trying to get interviews
to get the fuck out of there and
someone's like, yeah, yeah,
Sandy was football rules.
Fuck you and then runs off.
You're like, damn it. I was
so close to wrapping the day.
Now I've got to do another human being.
I had something bad happen.
I was stuck on the side of a road in
Hollywood on Saturday and it had to pee
really bad and,
but I wasn't anywhere near a bathroom
as a check point going on and stuff like
that.
So I had to pee.
I found a mountain dew bottle that I
was peeing in and pouring it out my my
window,
like I had to fill it up five times
cause you'd be amazed how much p actually
fits a mountain dew bottles. And this
person walked by my car just jogging,
like being healthy and she stepped
in my pee and she just see,
you're like looking down at the ground
going, what did I just step off?
It's a story is so layered.
I don't know where to start with.
You know what it's like, it's like
a Stanley Kubrick movie. It's not,
what you're seeing is
not what you're saying.
It's all about symbolism
and what the key represents.
Brian's common sense
says he's this leaking it out of his body.
Like he can't get it out
of his body quick enough.
There's way too much common sense.
Describe.
He starts the story and I saw
your eyes go, he's mad at me.
Can you tell just mad at me today.
I'm not mad at you at all.
I just told you many times not to talk
on the microphone like this because it
changes a sa the volume of the podcast.
And so when I, when I brought that up,
I felt you tense up. But it's just,
I'm just telling Ya. All right. Flying
Dildos. Tell me about this. Okay.
This is the,
this is,
this is what you were talking about
right before you told years. Damn.
They keep her story.
Can we smoke in here? Sure. So not
that I smoke, I don't smoke weed,
but I was just asking for you guys. So let
me tell you, you want us to mark up. Um,
so,
uh,
so I'm going to wait to
tell the story until you're
available. Joe. Someone has a Burt,
you watched the South Park documentary
last night, which was the most,
which was one of the most
amazing documentaries.
And so glad that led fucking good.
And one of the coolest things ever
was that Trey Parker and Matt Stone,
we're talking about a tripping on acid
when they had to go to the Academy Awards
and Matt Stone dressed up as a woman and
was Trey's a date during the thing and
they played clips on it.
And it was so weird seeing,
cause I had seen that interview before,
but now seeing Trey Parker on acid,
you could totally tell Joe is one of
the best documentaries I've ever seen.
It's literally a here, give it
back to Joe. Oh No, I don't smoke.
You don't smoke? No, I don't totally
defeated myself. We can get this to Joe.
I gotta fix this camera roll
real quick. Run out real quick.
Uh, oh here. Yeah. So, um,
I told him if he did whatever process.
So anyway, we have the south Pandosy
documentaries fucking out of this world.
Yeah. That's documentaries. I
was, I, I was thinking that,
wouldn't it be awesome if they took,
can we get to the flying, build those
first cause we might forget. Yes. Okay.
Flying Dildos. Here we go. So I called
Joe, this is what you said. You Go,
we were just talking about
this and you're like, yeah,
you got so many crazy stories that have
happened to you and it, and, and, and,
but I never think that,
I think there are just things in my life.
I think it's my ability,
the way I see something
happen is different than the
way everyone else sees it
happen. You know? I see the,
the little thing that, that
registers and me, I go all,
that's my thing,
you know,
and it lights up for me where my wife
just glazes over it and it's come to light
in this podcast more than
anything. The machine. I mean,
the way I've told the story
to fucking a million people,
but then when I told him to do
something lit up and I went, Ooh,
that is a good story, right? The fucking
fighting a bear, the fuck everything.
I'm getting mauled by a bull, Tracy
Morgan, everything's lights up.
So then I'm talking on the
phone today. I see you, hey,
can you do by do and you go.
I said,
I'm on the phone with Delta,
American Airlines trying to get upgraded.
You're like, where you going? I said,
Amsterdam. He said, I've never been there.
I said, oh, whatever you do, if you ever
go there, don't go see flying dildos.
True story, right. So, so
I'm fucking like 22. I'm at,
I'm an in Amsterdam where with
like five friends and there.
And of course we do the
rounds in Amsterdam and get
fucking lit up a Heineken
factory, hedge jobs, I
think even maybe mushrooms.
We walked by this live sex show and
it says on the billboard, guy on girl,
girl on girl, oral sex,
uh, this, this, this.
And then the last one is flying dildos.
Come see flying dildos
since all Mike fucking,
I tell everyone we're seeing fine dildos.
I want to see fucking flying deal does.
That to me is a showstopper.
That is something that I will
buy tickets for everyone for us.
Why buy us all tickets? We go in and see
a live sex show. Have you ever seen one?
No. It's basically like,
like half a boxing ring.
So it's like you walk in and it's stadium
seating and then half a boxing ring
where they just without the ropes they
just, everything happens right there.
They just fuck it. Just fuck and Oh and
our dudes beating off in the audience.
Are you allowed to wear lipstick? No.
Dude's aren't beating off in the audience.
No,
it's a,
it is kind of creepy now that you say
that because I don't know what we were
supposed to do, but there was like 20
people in there, but we sat in there yet.
I guess maybe you should have been, but
we didn't and we ruined it for everyone.
So we sit down and they're like, they come
out and they're like, the first is um,
girl on girl. This is just
like ut a porn, right?
So two girls come out and they're like,
they get,
they got to eat and I s and
just taken two girls come out.
I start going flying dildos,
flying doers and they're like, no,
we're not playing deldot's. I
go, ah, now do any guys are like,
well I want to see flying dildos too.
So they do their thing, they leave.
A girl comes out by herself, masturbation
and I go flying dildos and she goes, no,
I'm not flying dildos. I fucking, everyone
that came to the stage, I just yelled.
How many people came to the, and like
nine acts, nine acts come to the stage.
How about how long is each one doing?
Five minutes and fucking masturbating
and meeting each other out and then
blowing a dude and then the guy fucks a
girl that's like the headliner, right?
Like, and we get to the guy
fucking the girl and I'm like,
you better be fucking flying dildos. And
the guys like, we're not flinging dildos.
Okay, stop with the fucking
playing dildos. And I'm like, oh,
the whole time they're bugging,
they're fucking them. Yeah.
But now we've got 20 dudes and they're
all on my team because the fucking hammer,
we want flying dildos, right.
So then all of a sudden uptick,
dude, you'll violate it comes out
with a doctor's, a little briefcase,
you know the doctor's thing bag
and just walks up on stage. I go,
you better be fucking fine Dylan,
because ladies and gentlemen,
I am flying billers and the
fucking police nuts 20 dude,
that's like fucking right out of
the military guy, man. He goes,
I'm going to need and I'm going
to need someone from the audience.
And everyone's like, fuck fucking,
I am definitely going up there.
Of course he did.
So I get up,
I'm making up there and everyone's
chatting five those fucking dildos.
I got my hands up and she goes,
okay, okay. Hands behind back.
And I put my hands on my Mac and she
handcuffs me and everyone's like flying
dude. Like everyone's going
fucking nuts. She dropped my pants,
cuts my shirts with a scissors,
throws me on the back,
puts a dildo on my mouth and just
fucks it and then stands up. She goes,
that was flying builders and she leaves
me with a Dildo and my mouth naked on
everyone's taking pictures,
like fucking step right up to
them for like I had handcuffs on,
I couldn't fucking move and just snap,
snap, snap, snap Sessa and I'm just like,
oh somebody out. We get to do it out of
my mouth. It was a fucking nightmare.
So we'll have a photo of this.
This was in 90.
This is right after the Russian mob thing.
So this is there no digital cameras.
So it's real. My, I can tell
you if you want somewhere else,
someone out there has in a dusty shoe box.
He coups motto that they
brought back collar PJ,
PJ Cusumano um, has, has that picture.
I guarantee it because I know
he's one of my, one of my buddies,
it was on it with us.
He had one of those disposable cameras
and came right up there like right up to
the stage
and just snap. Snap. So you
say if you're out there,
find me on Twitter homie Stansberry the
whole time for make it worth your while.
Pj from the comedy store. Yeah. Yeah.
So do you ever go to the best PJ face?
I've ever seen him.
What'd you give him before the shows too?
I have no idea. I have, I have no idea.
He's extra silly today. He
just knows it's extra. Brian.
Today's extra bad weekends but I've
had a bad 2011 I'm done with it.
Like I want to bring on 2012 and
just off myself. It'll show up.
I think it works that way kid.
You've had a good 2011 you got to get
2011 by by a bad 2011 I think your 2011
still pretty fucking good dude.
Crazy craziest I've ever had ever.
I've never had so much crazy shit this
year. It's a lot of crazy stuff I've had.
Yeah. Yeah. You bring that on yourself,
kid. You're a lot of what Brian? Brian?
Like the secret 20 minutes ago you were
just talking about smoking oxycontin.
Yeah. Not going to make you look at
2011 in a positive light like yeah.
That's how the future
roles in strong dude.
Obviously he's smoking oxies
with Straw. Yeah. Come on.
At what point do you put the meth and
the light bulb and go little smoke it and
see what happens?
I tried it twice and it's like your,
that's like a drug that
you could actually take.
It's not like fucking psycho drug.
It's not like crystal meth.
This is actually a pill that's for
cancer patients or something like that,
but it's opiates. It's
heroin. It's heroin.
You think? Well, yeah. Okay. Very good
to be jump on your side on this argument,
but I'm on Joe's page.
Oh, 100% it's heroin.
Biddle level run a lot of pills
and I've never taken an auction,
but I've tried it.
Two hits of probably a hundred hits that
that pill gave off during the trial of
the group I was with, so I took two
hits of what other people were doing.
Two to 300 probably hits for the
whole night. Was that, wait, wait,
wait about two to 300 heads and they
were just pretty much puffing on the same
pill over and over again.
It was like,
it was like smoking a whole
bowl of weed or more, you know,
it would think anybody give up 300 hits
of Oxycontin and right now was probably
over exaggerated.
But his math is,
how crazy is that that you're willing
to smoke something and if you smoked it
300 times in the road,
fucking for sure Kelly,
you 100% they'll go one you'll go to.
But if you will got in 30 31 32 and
then you got into 50 pretty good self
control though.
No,
but I'm saying what I'm saying is when
you're doing is if you took two hits,
you know and you just kept going in really
did what you said people did 300 yeah,
he'd be dead.
That's crazy that you're willing to
take even two of those and you're like,
you're willing to step two
steps on the way to death.
Two steps on the way to a 300 step way
to drink alcohol. Yeah, sure. Same thing.
I'm not,
I'm not claiming that I'm above it.
I'm just saying it's a fascinating thing
called cause way more people fucking
drinking.
Yeah.
Wait, you're saying you could drink
alcohol and be fucking alcohol? Yeah.
Alcohol doesn't get more
people in the, he kills it.
Well, don't get, don't get wrong.
It tells a lot of people 100,000
alcohol Friday morning. I'll tell you,
there's 300 million
people in this country.
Roughly around 80 to a hundred thousand
people die every year from alcohol
poisoning, from alcohol induced
death, overdosing and alcohol.
Um, and then there's more that
die from drunk driving. That's,
that's well over 100,000 that die
from drunk driving. So that's,
that's what you get attributed.
The alcohol desk really,
you can only attribute the,
the poisonings though.
The rest of it is just doing things that
you can't control while you're drunk,
which is, you know, it's still
his death, but it's not, you know,
it's not like an LD 50 rate.
So it's like how many drinks would
you have to have before you died?
It probably not that many man.
Probably even less than oxy.
I mean we said 300 oxies would kill
your 300 hits of oxy would kill you.
Exaggerating.
I probably said they did like whatever.
A bowl of really a big huge bowl of wheat
cause I mean they were there for maybe
an hour.
Okay. My point was how many
shots can you, can you drink?
You can't even drink 20 shots.
You might be dead at 20 you might be dead.
If you had to 30 you might be dead
at 30 that's pretty God damn clothes.
That's a lot closer than 300 you
know? You know, sometimes you go five,
six Deepa at night, so you're a
quarter to weighted dead. Yeah. Ooh.
Are we talking about me
right now? [inaudible] you're
talking about human beings.
No. Yeah, they're definitely. Here's the
thing that's more dangerous about alcohol.
Did any of that is I have a buddy who goes
to Chicago, has a few bottles of wine,
take some allergy medicine or
whatever in the middle of the night.
Wakes up pass like drunk stumbling,
smashes through a fucking plate
glass coffee table. Oh my God.
Fucking destroys his face. Two kids.
Oh No. Just having some wine. Fucking,
I mean he was taking an allergy
or cold flu medicine or whatever,
but do you know,
but he's a grown up.
A lot of people have that old school
growing up mentality with her.
I'm a fucking grown up.
I can take care of myself.
I know I've done it a million times
and you go, ah, fuck it. I'm good.
I'm in a hotel room. What's I'm having?
I'm downstairs. I get in the elevator,
go upstairs.
What's the worse that can happen?
But body falls to a plate glass fogging
thing doesn't even know what he did.
Just wakes up in the middle of the night
base bloody calls his wife and she's
like,
I get you a first class ticket home and
we'll have a doctor look at you tomorrow
morning. Like what? That's the thing that
scares me about alcohol, not the Dui,
not the fucking liver shit. It's the
fucking immediate, you know that.
That's what terrifies me.
Shit like that.
Just a dumb accidents like you're drunk
and you're naked and you're like, oh,
suddenly a toenail breaking. Yeah, slip
and I fall in the showers three times.
Yeah. Not like you can get fucked
up in a shower. Man. Rubber.
That was just happened
to meet the other day.
I fell and I grabbed my stuff
right at the last second,
but I have a glass shower that door
and like it was really like I was looking
at going like this would have ended
really bad.
That's why I only use curtains worse.
It happens when you fucking fall in the
shower with the curt and the here and
then you're fucking on the ground.
Yeah, that's a good point. That's
scary as fuck. Fucking terrifying.
In the shower you can really,
people die like that every year.
I wonder what the numbers of that
are there. Probably like pretty high.
I bet it's a thousand people a year.
I mean it's more than than
whatever that drug was.
150 people die a year cause
coconuts falling head.
You know what though?
I started looking at the,
had we had a palm tree leaning over our
house and I started looking at palm tree
fatalities.
It's up there man.
Like those or tried those limbs
fall off hitch on the head.
The trees aren't saddled climate,
maybe two. I'll put those in there too.
I don't care. But those things aren't
deeply rooted so they fall over sometimes.
Really? They're very bendable cause
they're full of water but the,
there aren't deeply rooted trees so
they can fucking fall on houses easy.
So they just, you know you could be
walking by and they'll just land on you.
A palm tree frog.
Yeah.
We have a dude coming to our house on
Wednesday to get all our palm tree frons
out and we got clean palm trees
for like 75 bucks each tree.
But you've got to give me up on that shit.
Do you guys say cut those
things off your trees for yard?
They usually typically gay people.
Like is that a gay job to do?
What? Tree cutters? None of
that. Only specialize in palm.
That alarm. What you say?
Palm trees, right. Wait,
take. Took a break.
The uh, I had, no, no, he's Mexican and
he's a, he just came out and he's like,
he,
I got an email saying he needed to do
survey the area and then he came out and
he's clearly didn't speak any English
and he was like 70 70 and I go,
he's telling you 70 bucks.
I get this real fucking complex email
about him saying he needs to come out,
surveyed the area, take a look
at an appraisal after I get it.
And he gets an appraisal to come back
to me and he just comes out and he goes,
77, 70, 75, 75 70, right?
I go a tree and he goes,
sure. I go, perfect. And then he left.
Didn't say any more than that, but yeah,
that's the guy,
Mexican guy.
So he climbs up, make sure those things
don't drop on your head and kill you.
Climbs up.
He's cutting them all out tomorrow or
Wednesday that they're pretty fucking
heavy man. Dude, they're fucking monsters.
You were just tugged of ones and
that easily could kill you. Ease it.
You kill a child in a, in
a heartbeat. Ooh. Yeah.
That's why you gotta get
that shit taken care of.
We have one that hadn't been cut
and like by eight years in our,
in our front yard, that was our
neighbors and our neighbor was like,
and I was like, I got kids. Oh you
playing in the front yard dogs,
we can't have that.
She had fallen down.
How weird is that?
You have to worry about palm fronds
fucking yeah,
I know everyone.
Like of all the shit that was going to
kill me that I was going to be a plane
flight.
You keep talking about plane flights.
Do you really freak out about
playing fides? Fucking terrified.
Do you think in any way,
shape or form that all these fear and
worrying about things puts a certain
amount of energy out that attracts
negative things to you?
I do, but I believe that.
I feel like ignoring it
puts out a taunting energy.
Taunting what you're saying.
I'm not scared of you bitch.
You know what? Fuck it.
I'm not scared of flying anymore. That's
when God goes, ah, fucking see my rack.
So you have the Catholic version of God
where he has to fear you have to be or
excuse me, where you have to
fear him rather. Yeah. Will
you tell him your secret?
And he's like, yeah. He's like, well
who the fuck you think you're talking?
I'm talking about God right now.
You want to talk about some gay shit.
You talked to St Jude,
that's who you talked to you.
You don't talk to me about that shit.
So you think that by not thinking about
the plane crash by getting healthy about
it, then it would be like you weren't
respecting it exactly. 100% wow.
What a crazy way to look at things.
I have rituals for flying.
I wash it every part of my body.
Get all my hands and knees and say
a prayer in the shower. Really?
Fuck yeah cause I did it once and I
flew back at by me is that was going on.
I thought we fixed this.
Scoot out a little bit here.
We fix this so he could sneak by me.
Thank you. Got Bigger. Oh my, uh,
just Fyi, my web guy put up
something about the t, the shirts,
the machine shirts on burp or burt.com
they're taking preorders now we finally
got the fucking licensing of the image.
It's a fucking nightmare.
Licensing of your own image
was a nightmare. Yeah, because
I didn't create it. It,
same thing happened with my DVD.
My DVD has a shirt with a
carrot on it and it says hello.
It's a joke I have about,
if you're gonna put a vegetable,
the girl's ass don't use a cucumber.
That's like a home invasion. Use a carrot.
That's more like a, a low. So then we
couldn't get the licensing to the imaging.
I wouldn't give it to us. He goes, now,
I did it for the DVD. If you want it,
you give me like 20 grand. And I
was like, I was like, all right,
now we'll just won't ever sold this DVD.
And this is an artist that did this as an
artist, but in artists that worked for,
uh, whatever, the company
that distributed the DVD. Wow.
So he just needs in a box you out.
It was like, fuck it, you want it,
give me like give me that. I think is
offered was like 10 grand. I was like,
I don't have 10 grand man.
He goes, well you made,
you know that you've made that do
it. It's all in the shirts. Yeah.
That's ridiculous. So then, but, but,
but here's what happens is, so the guy,
we did the documentary and he made
the shirt, that machine shirt,
and he did it as a favor to his friends
took, we're doing the documentary.
So they were made specifically
for the documentary.
And then this is the documentary that
you're about to shoot. Yeah. And then,
and then, but I was like, Hey, can
we can sell those on the road and,
and the two group film guys
are like, fuck yeah. You know,
definitely will fulfill our documentaries.
Those will be special shirts
are not going to be all offered.
That shirt isn't gonna be offered, you
know, in the other color scheme. But yeah,
totally sell it. And so we went,
okay. And then the guy said, yeah,
you make it a college can do
whatever the one you could sell them.
And then the artists, we had to come back
to the artist and the artist was like,
no. I was like, why not? He's like,
because they're made for this documentary.
I did it for friends,
I didn't do it for you to go out
and make a fucking fortune on it.
And so then we had to kind of negotiate
to the guy and say, listen, you know,
I'm not, you know, it was,
it was a long process,
very long process of everyone
that seems like can hit the man,
want you making any money, man. He's just
like, yeah, and he did this for free, man.
It's from my friends. You're not my
friend. So then so other people want it,
right. And then it won't be underground
man. And then he's like, you know,
so anyway,
so we got him finally to say,
if you want to sell it on your
site or on on what you call it,
you can do it and you know,
negotiation shit.
And so we just put it on Burp or Berta
calm. But you can, you can order them,
preorder them.
I mean,
I think all the fulfillments have
to go out first and they're gone.
They're already out. But if you
wanna go to burp her birth to calm,
you'll find in the store,
you'll find the machine shirt and you
can now you can fucking stop emailing me
about where to get them and when to
get them there on how many emails you
getting a month is a fucking nonstop.
The day you warriors on a,
on the podcast fucking a million people
going like, hey man, I wanted to,
I want to do anything
in the documentary now.
Like I didn't know what the
shirt looked like. I was like,
are you fucking serious?
So
the documentary, the shirt is
what got them to want to do it.
Uh, the shirt that's like, that's
brilliant marketing the shirt man.
But we would've never gotten the short
made if we hadn't done the documentary.
But isn't that funny
that that works that way?
That someone sees a shirt and it's a
dope shirt and like this documentary is
gonna fucking rule. Yes. Cause they see
the shirt, but it's you, it's you. It's,
I mean like don't, don't like
undersell it. You're the first one,
but you're being a regular human being.
When you said as you go,
you gotta get me one asap.
Like I want to wear it on fear factor.
I want to wear it on the podcast.
So we rush it. We get it.
A couple of sent to you,
a couple sentences like other people
that we know that are important to us and
you wear it and it fucking blows up,
like literally blows up.
Well that's uh,
that's nice that I can do that.
It's a pretty easy we'll
have to do is wear a shirt.
Yeah. Or they feel like I did anything.
You know, you just made a bad ass shirt.
No chance to wear it. It's negative.
Yeah. So yeah. So if you want to get,
I'm gonna to burp her. Berta.
Com. Bert, Bert, Bert with ease.
Powerful. Bert. Kreischer so
what else, what else going on?
I don't know what the fuck's Brian Doing?
It's making video.
How, how sad are you about Steve Jobs? I,
it hit me pretty hard or harder than
what right. And it's harder then. No,
but like when anyone dies, like when like
Farley died, I was affected. I was like,
wow, you know, I've really
enjoyed watching Chris Farley.
That was kind of like I was connected
to him and I didn't know him.
Steve jobs kind of same way.
Like I effected me in a weird level and
I wasn't sad. I didn't cry or anything,
but I,
it's pretty amazing looking back at like
the videos of him giving speeches and
stuff like that.
Well, Steve Jobs was a bad motherfucker,
but like all bad motherfuckers,
he was flawed, you know? And um,
he was a ruthless dude and
did a lot of, uh, you know,
with a lot of people would say is
questionable shit. First of all,
they had fucking slave labor that we're
making the right phones. That's a, I mean,
it's Chinese.
These factories is Foxconn factories.
They have to have nets all around the
factories to keep people from jumping off
the roof. You know, there's,
there's a lot of weird Karma involved
and stuff like that. And you know,
I'm a total hypocrite because I have
an iPhone, you know, I mean, I'm not a,
I'm not boycotting
these companies that use
this, this kind of labor, but I
mean, it was pretty public. They had,
they have nets around these places to
keep people from jumping off the roofs.
They work 15 hours a day and they sleep
on cots and it's fucking gross, man.
It's gross. And it's scary that people
can be forced to live like that.
Just to survive in 2011 is open that he,
do you think he knew that?
He fought for sure.
Knew it.
He knew that he was aware of every single
aspect of every day to day operation
at Apple.
He was incredible CEO.
He's a guy who is completely
dedicated and, and, and,
and love with every facet of his company.
And he was just a bad motherfucker.
He had to have know
where they're being made.
If I know where the fucking
phones are being made,
he knows where the phones are
being met and this ridiculous,
it's a ridiculous to think he did.
No, no. I know Megan is also,
they fucking claim that the,
I didn't know there was child labor,
like I didn't know that.
You think they knew it.
Yeah.
He's also incredibly ambitious and the
reason why the company became so good is
because he was so ruthless and
incredibly ambitious and because of that,
you know, he was, he was a tough guy
to work for for some people. Some,
some people will tell stories about
him yelling and screaming at people and
calling a maze.
But that's because he wanted so much of
himself and the reason why he was such a
bad mother fucker,
he's had these incredibly high standards.
So then to have all these other people
working under him and some of them who he
didn't feel like met his vibration,
met his frequency. He would be upset,
at least as far as everything
I've ever read him at him,
he just seems like another tortured,
brilliant person, you know,
who had an incredible gift of vision
for this computer company. You know?
I mean I, I, like I said, all
bad motherfuckers are flawed.
You can't get to be amazing at something.
You know what?
Remember when Clinton got busted pulling
his dick out and we were all like, ah,
there's a part of us that, it was
like, it was a breath of fresh air.
There was a part of Clinton getting caught
getting his dick sucked in the White
House was like, okay, no one's
got it all together. No one does.
Not even the fucking president.
No. Wait. Do you believe, how
about this? What about this theory?
I was just saying this to Brian today
in the car ride. What if, what if the,
what if the flaw shows up when you get
there as opposed to it's always there.
Do you think there's an inherent flaw
that shows up with guys like Steve Jobs
when you become Steve jobs and you walk
into a room and everything you say is
what's not really a flaw? You
know what I mean? Look, it's,
it's just a quality and is the quality
of Steve Jobs was that he was just,
his vision was much clear, has
his, will was much stronger. His,
his ideas carried more weight. He just
knew how to put it all together and do it.
He had a, uh, a pure vision of what he
wanted the company to be like. It's not,
there's not, that's not a bad
thing. You know, those, these,
this obsession is just how
he chose to live his life.
He chose to live his life in
this obsession for excellence
and the, in the end,
we're all temporary man. In the
end, we just ceased to exist.
We're here for a short period
of time and then we're gone.
If you want to live it like that,
man,
you want to burn that candle a birth at
both ends and make a big when it reaches
the middle, why fucking not w what?
What is the difference? Is it,
is it better to die slowly? What
I don't understand. I don't know.
I don't understand.
I think a guy like that that comes along
and just [inaudible] and makes this big,
incredible explosion. That's a pretty
fascinating individual, but you know,
I think it's important to look at them
as honestly as possible. You know,
like anybody who died,
it's funny. I'd never heard nothing but
nothing, but absolutely like he's a god.
He changed everything and to hear their
perspective, I never heard it that way.
I never saw it that way. At least
this comes from a fan, you know?
I don't take you as,
I think you're being more objective.
It was like I talked to my dad about the
Wall Street occupation today and I was
wondering where his perspective
was going to come to. My Dad's.
My Dad's like you in the
sense that he's like,
there are things I'll say to
you sometimes when I'll go, oh,
I think Joe Joel believe this.
And then I say it to you and you go,
are you fucking retarded? And then I
go, but like, but my dad's the same way.
My Dad's a regular dude who by the way,
she'd be on fucking Alpha brains,
but really? And my dad wants to
do alpha brain so bad. He's like,
please send me some and I will document
it. And my dad said that to me.
Oh my dad fucking asked about Alpha brains
and was like, watch, assign it to him.
Brian. I don't even have alpha. Right. And
I ran out like, today's just some dude.
But um, but yeah, but, but the,
we were talking about the Wall Street
occupation and I was like, I was like,
I don't,
I don't know where to fucking like,
I like Jamie Kilstein and I know he's
like at the head of the New York one,
but occupy Wall Street occupy,
I think it's a great idea to scare the
fuck out of those corrupt cons. Yeah.
But what's going to happen? Thing 90% of
the people are just there for a party.
They're just there for
a big protest and intimidate.
And Neal Brennan,
I think it was just did a standup
comedy for occupy la I think.
And I'm like, now they're having
comedy shows. This is pretty sweet.
This could be like the next,
you know, let's try it.
Wunderman look last this cause
he, how it starts, you know,
we're joking around about this now.
Like it's no big deal, but look,
essentially what keeps a country
together a government and essentially the
Internet has exposed the fact that our
government is absolutely corrupt and
absolutely incompetent and almost
every single way, and not just corrupt,
but corrupt to the point where they're
starting wars for no fucking reason for
profit.
And that's pretty well been established.
And if that's been established
and there is no government,
we just don't got a bunch of corrupt cont
criminals that are running the fucking
people into the ground and
they have this fake system,
this fake monetary economic system
that's just fucking built on unfixable
bullshit. Just a porous fibrous. This.
There's no fixing it. It's, it's
impossible to shore it all up.
You would have to completely start
from scratch with a whole new thing and
dissolve all the money, which is
fucking never going to happen. You know,
in a lot of people get mad when I
started talking about economic things.
They go Joe Rogan, you know
him, know nothing about
economics. And you know what?
You're absolutely right.
I don't know nothing about economics,
but I do know bullshit. I know
bullshit and lady, it has.
I've been how, how I've been explaining
as it's been explained to me the,
I know it's bullshit. You know, it's
bullshit too. It's not even based on goal.
It's based on fucking confidence and
it's run by [inaudible] and if that's the
case, what is going to happen eventually?
We'll fuck man, this shit my fall apart.
It really might fall apart.
Well,
we're enjoying right now this calm and
chaos is like us being taken care of by
our overlords.
US being taken care of in our slave
quarters and we're like dealing with it.
But when we asked to be free,
man, we may, we better be ready.
We better be ready for whatever the fuck
that means. I'm ready. Not even close,
man.
If would've ordered Wall Street just
walked out and occupy Wall Street and
they're like, fine, you guys take over.
Yeah. They'd be like, hold
on. Where's the lighter?
How does anybody ever gonna
figure out what money is again?
I mean obviously they
could never walk away, but,
but how is anybody gonna
to refill in our lifetime?
It would take so many lifetimes happen,
I think. I mean, I would imagine,
and people who are rich right now are
never going to accept it and people will
owe people money or never going to accept
that person owes money and now they
don't anymore. We'll fuck you, man. I gave
you that money. He never paid me back.
You douchebag. Now once we figured
out a new system of government,
you better give me my money back.
You know,
there'll be like old debts that people
are gonna want to bring into play,
but it's,
but you know,
I understand what they're saying in a
sense that that we tried to apply for a
home loan this year and it was a fucking
nightmare. Like getting a home loan.
They have this money,
they can give this money and they
choose not to for ridiculous reasons.
And so fucking like,
I understand that in a lot of it.
I do believe that is the small
businessman that keeps America afloat.
It's not the corporations.
Well,
you know,
corporations don't hurt as long as they
pay a good wage and they have union
labor and they take care of everybody.
But I don't mind the corporations.
Obviously people start going on
about, you know, uh, you know,
unions want too much money and that's why
corporations have to go down to Mexico
and they forced these jobs overseas.
Like,
or is that really the
only fucking solution?
Is it really the only solution to
get people to work for slave labor?
That's the only silly to get people to
work for some ridiculous wage that you
would never, I, it doesn't make any sense
to me. We always manufactured things.
We've got to figure out a way
to manufacture things here.
And does that mean that they cost more
money? I don't. Maybe, I don't know.
I don't know. But figure it out. Don't
use fucking slave labor, man. You know?
I mean, I'm such a hypocrite because I do
have an iPhone and I do know about this
Chinese company that makes iPhones,
but really at the end of the day, man,
you're attached to that in
one way and some form you're,
you're connected all the way back,
you know,
to these people wanting to jump off a
roof to make your fucking cell phone.
Is there a way to make cell phones and
America, Brian, you would know this.
Can they do that?
Can they just start making an iPhone
be more expensive, more
expensive? $20,000 yeah.
I mean, these people are beginning
Peyton, nothing. You know what?
Before this company was there,
they're probably laying on the ground
shivering with snakes coming out of their
asshole. You know, who knows
Casey resign as the companies,
the countries.
We're all fucked up before it
was before. Yeah. Well you know,
you've got to put good point there,
but with these South American countries
especially, you know, yeah. These, these
poor Fox,
they were tearing down their rain forest
and put an oil fields out there and
ruining their,
their land.
We went in with our clothes
and our all our shit,
all that east western Shit and
dumped it on them and said,
this is the way it's going to be like,
you know, I mean look at, look at,
you don't expect to see a guy improve
wearing slacks and a collared shirt and a
fucking tie. But we said, do that shit.
We cut your re enforce down, we're ready.
Join the team. And then
we're like, oh by the way,
it's a nickel a day and
you've got to live in a cage.
Is it even possible that we could come
up with really efficient robots that do
most of the work and have the,
the phones and all these fucking things
made in America and pay people an honest
wage and instead of a phone
raking in $800 you know,
making a, you know, what if they have
a phone that they sell for 800 bucks,
like what is the profit
for them? You think, uh,
that was a problem for apple book is 70%
70% you think along with manufacturing
and all that shit. Do you think it's
that high? I think it was pretty high.
Livwell we're, we're totally speculating,
right? And I'm too lazy to Google this,
but, so let's just for the sake of
this argument, just pretend it's 70%.
Let's go with what you say.
So they make a 70% province.
I'm inclined to think it's not that high
because I'm inclined to think that with
production costs and then with advertising
and apple spends a lot of money on
yeah, but an iPhone right
now, they sell retail price,
like the new iPhone four s I think as
$899 for the cheapest version without a
contract or something.
It was either seven or nine or nine
or eight 99 $400 for a new upgrade.
I know that my wife
just looked at it today,
but if you want to buy one
f flat out, well you know,
and then you've got to well,
either way.
Okay,
so do the 70 you think an iPhone
really costs that fucking watch? No.
You know that shit screen is so cheap.
They have fucking screens. They have what?
A $20 Indian,
a laptop right now or an
iPad that just was released.
It's like $36 I think it was to buy.
No, I know what you're talking about.
Those are her children to
learn the alphabet. Yeah,
but the screen size is way
bigger than the iPhone.
What I'm saying is the parts
they mass manufactured there.
They're definitely using this
cheap labor and stuff like that.
I bet it is something like a 70%
profit, we'll say, but I'm going to,
I'm going to just jump in for $200 really?
I'm not going to justify it
$100 but let's, we're not,
I'm not talking about the dudes who had
paid to make this. That's not what my,
where my money's not going to those
those 20 Asian dudes that put the phone
together. I'm talking, my money's
going to the guy that made it,
the guy that fucking said,
this is how we do it.
You can't pay that guy $5 an
hour because he won't do it.
You need that 800 offset of 70% profit
where Steve jobs has got a a dialogue.
Jobs at the end of the day has $7
billion in the bank and his body fails.
All right.
Yeah,
but think of all the fuck [inaudible]
think of all the companies that did not
exist, like the Macintosh or the, the,
the myths Chubashi Hand Gel.
You know, like the one, the,
all the phones that you've
seen that you didn't buy right
there. Just fucking keeping their
head above water. Steve Jobs,
just having to come up with
the sexiest one that all of us,
despite sometimes our moral beliefs
when I fucking want the phone,
like in a way,
never thought about anything other than
wanting the phone until I found out
about the factories.
But even still after the factories,
did you switch over to whatever
the Google one? They tried it,
but it was 10 and so that, that's
my point. That's my point. You Go,
one's probably made the same way.
Make them in other countries.
They make them in Mexico. I'm not
saying yeah, but my, my, my point is,
it's not that he deserves his 7 billion,
but the point is he did do a magic trick.
They got us all to fucking,
even despite knowing what we
know about how they're made,
we went still fucking with the
phone. Here's the question. It,
would it be possible to do the exact same
thing but do it in America and instead
of him making $7 billion,
he makes four. How's that?
Is that possible that you could have done
it exactly the same way and everybody
makes a shitload of money but you, you
spread it around more. Is that possible?
But it is possible for
a Steve jobs to do it,
but it's not possible for the guy that
did the Google phone because the guy that
did the Google phone would not only be
broke but everyone would be fucking broke.
Like you know you got, it's like,
so you're saying once it becomes,
he's had some things out there on
the market, he's hedging his bets.
The guy that made the Google phone
probably just made a nice living,
didn't make the 7 billion. Well, you
know, it's a, first of all it's Google.
You know, they have, they have their own
phone operating system and they, you know,
I mean it's not like a guy. I know. I
know, but I know, but I'm trying to,
I'm trying to a broad stroke it or like
a whatever the other fucking phones are
out there. The smartphone. So you're
saying they can't make them in America.
They couldn't make them at
a more reasonable profit in
America. Uh, if they did,
if they had and they said, okay,
well instead of best case scenario,
instead of us being up mass hit like
the iPhone and we all walk away with 7
billion, we're willing to walk away with 5
million each. Right. Well, when it isn't,
when he's just average the way it was,
they were all lost their asses.
They would have all look like the deficit,
the deficit we're looking at there
is totally different. In my opinion.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about Joe. I'm pretty fucked up right now.
Okay. But I'm saying, I'm just
saying like you're losing me. No,
I'm saying I see what you're saying,
but I don't think that they're
losing venture making droid phones,
especially these really bad ass
ones. They may like the, you know,
the HTC evo is and the droid bionics,
the Motorola bionic, whatever.
I don't want that shit. What
do you mean? I don't want that.
I want the iPhone cause I saw a dude
have one on a plane one time and I went,
I went that shit.
So whatever that thing you did created is,
makes me want it that in a weird way,
you earn your 7 billion. Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean in a weird way. Yeah. You know,
look, he created a cult, you know,
the cult of Mac and I'm a, I'm a user, you
know what I mean? So like I said, I'm a,
I'm a huge hypocrite. I thought, I think
they have the best operating system.
I'd love it. It doesn't crash. I
never get viruses. I have no issues.
It's a little more expensive.
Yes it is.
You're writing jobs didn't
die from the virus. Joe.
I want you to go home.
You listen to spot weird energy. I agree
with what you're saying. I, anyway,
side note. Uh, I just think that,
I think that they probably weren't set
up originally to try to make 7 billion.
They were best case and I
was like a million each and
then Josh blew the fuck up.
And you're right when that guy,
there's a lot of stories about him doing
business. It's totally stupid. Well,
but once you get to that place where
you're the dude that made the sexy thing
that everyone wants and you're the God
that created all this fucking microcosm
of belief,
of cult of personality about you,
you start believing what the fuck
you feel and you go, fuck it.
I'm indestructible and you're right.
I do believe that it's Karmic energy
that snapped back on him from all the
negative shit he put out there.
But I didn't,
well, I'm not saying that. I don't
think that's why he got sick. You know?
I think if, if anything, you probably got
sick cause he works too much. You know,
I think when you and your that type
of person that can't turn it off, man,
that's an incredible amount
of strain in your system,
your red line in your system all day,
man.
When you're like a super intense
success oriented, goal oriented,
victory oriented, sort of a
guy like Steve jobs. I mean,
he wasn't just a visionary man.
He was like a cult leader.
He created a cult and didn't
even ask anybody to join
the cult. They just joined,
but he just joined it,
followed it everywhere and I would have
conversations with people at work when I
was on news radio. This
is, I realized it would,
they would be like super excited about
Apple's new announcements and the attack.
Talk to you about the new
announcement here. Apple's
new announcement. Yeah. Yeah.
They're working on the Osx right now
and then they get now it's crazy.
It's like that now for real. It's
like Hari Krishna Shit, you know?
I mean, think of a guy that's
basically a stand at a podium and go,
everyone do me a favor right now.
Throw away your fucking phones
and everyone just going,
I want the next thing he's got.
That's what we all do. Right.
He just stood up there and
like fucking take the purple
lemonade or whatever. I think of what it
is though is a lot for me. Creativity.
I've never in my life ever been able to
take what I'm thinking in my head and
put it out exactly how I want to
put it out. He created a tool.
He created a hammer,
he created a brush.
He created something completely different
and then sometimes I think people look
at what he's done is create
something that never existed before,
which was taking what I'm thinking in my
head and putting it into a format that
I could show you what I'm thinking.
You know,
like create creativity has
never been done before.
Since I've got an apple,
you know like using like final cut pro
and all the programs that he's given me,
I'm now really feeling like,
like,
like it's a tool like a hammer.
Wait,
are you understanding this? Because
I can sort it, I can translate.
I was saying that it helps them create,
well, I mean, think of Brian Brian Base.
Think of Brian,
you know,
10 years ago before apple was around the
jawline dude sitting on a guy sitting
in a room with a bunch of ideas
that he wanted to come out.
He wanted to do when I'm using two VCRs
to try to make a movie where now I'm
fucking filming on an iPhone doing HD
and Adl and arguably you are a much more
successful human being today than
you were when pcs were around.
Your ideas can happen quicker, faster
and you can get them to more people.
Think of the voice as
interesting as it had been today,
how many people has gotten too just
because of apples and Max. I mean that's,
I see what you're saying.
I mean it would've,
we would've gotten most of it done
with windows. I mean, I don't, I don't,
I disagree. Yeah. I mean, I've used
pampers before and it like, really?
I could get my, my, my emotions out
there, but it's not the same as like,
if you look at it not be the same,
might not be as good. But Dude,
there's a lot of people who edited videos
and did a great job and they edited
them on pcs. You know,
there's a lot of Photoshop PC.
It's what I'm saying, PC,
when you're talking to him,
all the jobs created the first PC.
Yeah.
But he didn't create the Windows operating
system and Xerox have computers put
the PC.
Xerox already have the graphic
user interface before apple did.
I'm pretty sure they did. I'm not
sure they got a good idea from zero.
You ever heard of a xerox personal
computer in your life? Do I have it?
But they could have existed. You know
what I'm saying? I mean, it's like,
and we know that windows did and we know
that a bunch of different people make
windows computers. I think computers
would exist in some form no matter what.
I think once the technology
was introduced into the world,
it's just a natural chain of progression
that people automatically start
incorporating into their lives and
then it becomes better and better.
What apple was was the best one,
right,
but it's not like the computer
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for apple.
What apple was was the best,
and by the way,
Wazniak was the technical genius
behind that. It wasn't even Steve Jobs.
It would have existed, man. Computers
would have existed, but no doubt about it.
Apple does it the best and they do it.
The sexiest you're hitting on Steve Jobs,
man does is on a Mac. This is a Mac to
your left. You're going to Mac over there.
I bought all these bitches. I
know. That's what I'm saying.
Why you hating on Steve
Jobs not hating on him.
I'm just trying to get the Steve jobs
loving and you're like, what am I talking?
All I said was that he's a ruthless
dude and that all bad motherfuckers have
their flaws and you got to look at him
for who he really is. Not very isolated.
Did you say I sad. I'm so, did you say
I'm not very, I said, that's hilarious.
Give me some hilarious. I said,
that might be, then let's the
line of the night, you know, like,
I can't wait to see in like four or
five years when Steve Jobs plans,
I've run out. Like I bet there's a couple
of that they just threw in there like,
oh, he didn't really perfect this
idea yet. Like smelly computer.
Now I don't want to see like just taking
all the ideas that you put down on
paper and they're like, guys, it's
a helicopter. I helicopter. Yeah,
we're all going to have them
one day. So wait, can I, can I,
is this possible that I just, just with
the energy that we're having today,
can I ask how you guys met?
Oh yeah. I met Brian Online.
Brian was on my message board. Yeah.
Well, Brian was posting these videos.
There were super creative.
That's good. Brian's best. Dot.
He's a wizard video editor. I
mean, even if it wasn't a room,
I would say for real. He's
a weird guy. You know,
obviously you can tell he's a
very silly, silly man. He's,
but because of that,
he has a sensibility when it comes to
video editing that I've never seen before.
It's, it's so, and so,
uh, his, his sense of humor is so his,
and you're fucking great at a man.
You really need to make more videos,
not just like little like edit videos
because they're fucking amazing man.
And so I met him, he was doing these
videos just for a goof and I was,
I met him at one of my shows and he was
on my, my message board all the time.
And I said, what do you do
for a living man? He said,
he works for gateway computers and like,
you want to work for me? And he's like,
yeah, I'm like, come on out
to come fucking California.
Which is curious. Yeah.
So he came out to California and that's
back in the comedy store days where, uh,
Brian used to film crazy
people coming up to us.
It was always like one fucking
crazy retard after another.
Brian would take these videos and make
these hilarious little things out of them,
little clips. And, um,
that's how we became friends.
So interesting.
I always wondered about that.
I thought I was having a
much more romantic story.
You never is the I love good.
Hey,
by the way,
I'm still mad at people
hating on restaurants that
are like chain restaurants.
Like, like I went to the olive garden
last night and had the best meal ever.
Another fucking impromptu all garden.
Here's what [inaudible] going to go to.
And by the way,
check this out.
Worst segway guy.
There's a Sushi place in studio city
that has this famous Sushi thing called,
I think it's called Sardo's or
something. No, it's not sorry guys.
But some other place,
Katina or something Qatar.
And they had this like all you
can eat Sushi thing for $26 right?
So my girlfriend's like, oh, I went
to Sushi and I'm like, all right,
let's get Sushi. So we sit down
and then we were like, all right,
we'll have the all you can eat Sushi
do. And so we ordered three, two, she's,
and they give you like the mungus
thing of Sushi. So it's not like,
like six roles. It's like 12 rolls each.
So I'm like, Oh shit, this better be good.
It's all rice and Raul, mushy fish. So in
Beta, same thing right now. Keep going.
Fuck does this have to do a little,
we were talking so,
so we start eating it and then we're like,
this is disgusting.
And the woman comes over and I'm like,
Hey, this is gross. And I'm like, sorry,
you have to eat at least a 75% and
I'm like, what? 75 Pr. Alright.
And my baby, I was like, I'll eat it,
I'll eat it and we'll get something else.
It will be better than,
than this shit.
So I ate all of it and then I
feel like I'm gonna Puke. Right?
Like it's the worst Sushi ever.
This is the one that you can tell
how ridiculous Brian Stories are.
How many likes there are in
there. Yes. And so like, and
she's like, and he's like,
and I'm like, oh my God.
Like, so my girlfriend's like,
I feel sick. Can we stop?
Can we,
can you just,
can we pretend we're doing the directorial
element element on this? So wait,
my favorite part is when
the lady says to him,
you have to eat 75% of it to even
have this conversation. He goes,
don't worry. I got this. I'm going
to be 75% of the Sushi and I,
I ate the whole thing because I was
just trying to prove a point. Right?
Like this is bullshit that you're
forcing me to eat this horrible Sushi.
Probably have to get rid of it
for it. Right, right. I know.
That's what I'm thinking.
I'm thinking the same thing
like that and then my genius.
I'm glad you thought of the same thing.
I told the waitress,
the waiter to come back and I'm
like, look, my girlfriend feels sick.
We don't even want to try for any
more Sushi because this is awful.
I'm sorry. You have to eat it. You know
what's the point of the story, man?
Was there a point? Yeah, because I went
to the olive garden and guess what?
None of that shit ever
happens at the off guard.
I'm not sitting there disappointed.
I'm like, no, this salad is awesome.
These breadsticks are awesome.
This is awesome. This is awesome.
This is often the point of this whole
side track is that all of Golf Garden,
all you can eat pasta and everything
costs me $40 that shitty ass Sushi,
51 bucks.
Who would want to listen to this?
You realize that this is a podcast who
the slug would want to listen to you talk
about how angry no, Brian, I'm being
honest with you. This is, this is,
this is a product. This podcast has
a product that I take very seriously.
I really love doing it and
if you actually, and people
enjoyed it very much. No,
I did not ask you.
You went off on a wild,
crazy chase to tell me that there's places
that are bad restaurants in the olive
garden always gives a quality.
You know what I'm thinking?
It's like people that get that bash
on franchise record about that.
Forget about that. What I want
to know is, are you, you know,
people except perfected this shit.
People are listening to this,
entertaining in that. No, definitely.
So when people say mom and pop restaurants
are the only way to go. Like I this,
this restaurant is good because
it's owned by small family.
There's need to go there and you just
have worst horrible, shitty ass. Right.
Bryce service is a dumb conversation
because not every mom and pop restaurants
sucks. No, but the majority
of them are. That's not true.
That is true restaurants Brian.
That is not true.
That's why they have kitchen nightmares
cause all these places can't make money.
So there's like this,
they're more likely to go under because
the bad restaurants and occupy Wall
Street. Okay. I'm going to
be judge Judy right now.
You are right on the part of what you
said and you were writing on the part of
what you said your role in the last part.
What my mamma's shit.
Pop shops are good. I know. No, I'm
not saying they're not. No, no, no, no.
You're wrong.
And the fact that no one wants
to hear what you just told us,
however shows chose all on the fact
that what it is then turned interesting
cause it was so bad because it was so bad.
So bad in a genius way.
Cause I'm sitting here laughing,
going, I can't believe that we're,
I think it's important to remind everybody
that someone's listening. This is,
ours is a program.
This is entertainment program,
and just get apologetic for edit stories.
It doesn't go to stores.
I apologize for talking.
Not Describe.
Aspire to a higher level, sir.
No, you guys are, I'm laughing.
I'm having a good time. This isn't
even remotely uncomfortable. Joe,
why are you so uncomfortable right now?
Dude, you're being weird. Despite that,
I can feel angry right
now and I'm not you.
You've been awkward this entire podcast.
I'm always awkward, every podcast,
but this is extra. No,
it's not. It's just,
it's on the same as drinking beers
with Bert Kreischer. It's about right.
I'll stop drinking.
Guys.
I may switch to energy drink because
I feel bad now because I'm making Joe
Awkward. Well, Brian, you mean
you, are you happy with that story?
How that all turned out?
Well, obviously, obviously
it was a little bit more intense
than I thought it was going to be.
A talking about how I like going to a
franchise restaurants because they do it
right and they've figured it out.
They get service,
good food compared to go
into getting food poisoning.
The be honest as a person who
likes listening to podcasts
as a person who enjoys
quality conversation, where you
happy with that? How'd that turn out?
Not your reaction,
but I was happy at how my story with the
story with the end result of the story
just answered.
I apologize for bringing up the guys.
Are you happy with how the end
result of the no, definitely not.
I'm not having outlets ending right now.
I did not mean to to turn
into whatever happened.
No.
And Are you happy with it as a product?
Like it was a piece of art as
a conversation, wouldn't you?
Wouldn't you say that in retrospect
it wasn't that entertaining?
I think you're taking it
different than what I, I'm just,
I'm just trying to find out your,
the way you approach it,
the way you approach telling a
story. If I, if I'm telling a story,
I want to make sure that it's entertaining
and if I think it's not going to be
entertaining, I don't want to tell it.
I think that's what you have to do.
And if I tell a story in it and we all
have, and it's not that entertaining,
I feel uncomfortable.
And you don't seem to feel that when
you tell a story and it doesn't work out
that good,
it doesn't seem to bother you at all.
Okay. Sorry. Does that
make sense? Yeah, but,
but, but I'll argue once
again to be the, okay.
Um, I will say that I think, and
I don't mean no offense by this,
but I think me and you have
a higher threshold, like a,
a titer threshold of when our
stories aren't doing well,
where we get more uncomfortable
as a performer. But he's been not,
it hasn't been doing it.
What,
27 years and 15 years he's
been doing it a hand like six.
So I think our threshold,
like when I bomb, I know what
it feels like, like that.
Like, I think, I think he's hoping it's,
I can't believe we're talking about this,
but he'll be,
I think
I thought we were just
off. No, no, no, no.
I think I didn't know
different directions.
Change the conversation in the middle
of this conversation went to this weird
olive garden thing and you
bring up the olive garden.
Are you against the other guy? Because
I'm not getting paid by the olive garden.
Is that what you think I'm talking about?
Like I have no connection to the
gardening and this just start dating.
I am sorry for bringing up the olive
garden. I will change it to Applebee's.
I'll tell you what. Or if you guys want,
I'll tell you about the time I did.
The girl that had cerebral palsy.
What's that like? I don't know.
We'll just see if that goes somewhere.
I don't know. I'm not certain,
but I didn't know stream. I didn't know
pretty extreme. Patrice O'Neal was, uh,
was like, it's fucking obvious. I
don't know how you didn't see it. Whoa.
But I didn't see it cause I was drinking
so much around her that were when you
met her? Yeah, we were on a plane. Whoa.
Flying from La to New York and I beautiful
girl sitting next to me and I just
automatically,
whatever thoughts you're going to have
her overwhelmed by how hot she is.
She was like,
Angela,
Angelina Jolie meets a Sarah Michelle
Gellar really smoking hot. And so, um,
so I sat down next to her and she just,
we just hit it off. It was so great,
but we were sitting next to
each other the whole time.
We didn't get up and go anywhere.
So I didn't see her walk.
And then we went out the next night
in New York on a date with a bunch of
friends, had a great time, Bam, like
so awesome. And then on the third day,
my buddy who pulled me aside,
he was like,
you might want to go out with her and
the sunlight and like check her out.
I was like, why? He was like, I think
something's wrong with the chick was like,
what do you mean? I didn't notice a thing.
I didn't notice a thing wrong with her.
I thought she was perfect and then
I go out with her in the sunlight.
It took her onto like a brunch.
I met her at her house.
She was a trust fund kid too,
which made it even harder.
But she was wearing
sneakers and I was like,
that's an odd choice for
a brunch is track shoes,
like sneakers with a sun dress. And then
I saw her lip and I was like, oh fuck,
something's going on.
And then we ate dinner.
She only used or like left
hand or her right hand one,
one hand the whole time to do
everything with. And I was like, fuck,
she's got several Paul.
Like I didn't know.
But then I found out and then you
become the guy that you're like,
will I date the girl with cerebral palsy
and or will I be the guy that goes,
fuck you. I don't want you to die soul.
I don't want that hassle of my life.
And I was like, fuck it.
I'm going to date her.
I liked her when I didn't think
she had cerebral palsy and then,
and now I know what, I'm not going
to fucking throw her to the wolves.
And so I started dating her and then
she went to Scotland with me and Patrice
and rich Vos and fucking, she showed
how crazy she was. She was a nightmare.
But trees was the first theater.
He's like, I don't like your bitch.
Crazy end cerebral palsy. Really crazy.
I think the, yeah, I think, you know,
I'm sure it's her history that's
got to creep in on her, you know,
having a disability.
But she was a fucking nightmare.
Like one night she was standing at the
foot of my bed naked and screaming at me
going, you won't fuck me. Fuck me.
You and Patrice walked like literally
walk stuck his head and he was like,
all right and shut the
door. It was, she was crazy.
We were in a a house in Scotland doing a,
the Edinburgh fringe festival and
then she was a nightmare fucking,
but my biggest thing was like,
man,
how much it would drunk do you have to
be to not notice the chick you're dating
has cerebral palsy?
Like I guess if you were totally trashed
and you just try and look at the bright
side of things. So yeah. But you know,
your first few days with a check, he,
it's out. How many dates did you
have before you took her away to,
to until I realized she had
cerebral palsy. Two or three.
It took you to hold dates before you
realized, oh yeah, like two whole days.
It's like hanging out and
walking around with her. Wow.
You know what it is something that would
even fucking weirder about it is that
she was a massive fan of guns and roses.
And then when,
when I was doing the act
show with Gary Valentine, um,
we ended up interviewing slash from guns
and roses and so slash showed up at,
and I was like, man, this chick, I can't
remember her name right now, but I go,
this chick love slash my color.
I had a number on my cell phone and
call her and I said, just so you know,
she lived in La. I go slashes in my,
in my green room right now, drinking,
if you want to meet slash
I've got to drive on for you
over at the gate. Come on.
And he's going to be here for awhile.
We haven't even started taping and he's
not flying out until 10 and he wants to
stay in my room drinking. So she showed
up to the taping, she sits in the,
in the back and watches me do
the interview with him and,
and it was great interview and then
we get done. And I said to her,
go to my green. And I told one of
the guys, figured in my green room,
so me and slash or one of the green
room with her, I go, I go, listen.
And slash just so you know,
this chick I dated, um,
is a big fans of guns [inaudible]
roses and she just wants to meet you.
And they talk and man,
and she is hottest fucking Shit and
slashing are pretty hammered it for like
eight in the morning.
And then she gets up to go to the bathroom
and I see her distinctively like limp
to the bathroom and walk out of my room
and slash looks over at me and he goes,
how perfect is she? And I was like,
you didn't see her limp. And he's like,
what are you talking about?
And I was like, great,
I'm just as big an alcoholic as slash
like slash didn't notice and I didn't
fucking notice. But yeah, so
she was fucking crazy though.
To how long did dinner for uh,
Scotland?
You got rid of her after that got rid of
her Scotland and then kinda hooked back
up with her in La
because you couldn't get a Dui because
no one could give her a fucking wrote
field sobriety tests or what?
Can they just give her brother
and I was there or they could,
but when she did a field service
he goes, oh, I have several palsy.
And they'd be like, oh, okay.
They feel uncomfortable. Oh
No, don't worry about it.
So she ever drunk with cerebral palsy?
Oh, all the time. Whoa. She was,
uh, she, she's done not listening
to that. She was a hot mess.
Juanque with cerebral palsy and
driving. Yeah. And only can use one arm.
Cerebral Palsy is just like,
it happens and then it's there forever.
It doesn't like escalate.
Really? Yeah. It's like,
it's like you got no brain delivered to
your don't know oxygen delivery to your
brain when you're a baby and then it,
you, she had like a hook, not a hook hand,
but not a whole can.
But like, uh, like uh,
this hand and then her leg was really
skinny. Wow. I remember boundaries.
She were when we were in Scotland where
these really hot leather pants and been
trees just leans over and he's like,
nice pants on your girl. Too Bad.
There's a baby leg, Jesus of
bugging beast. But anyway,
yeah, we partied and then one
night she was a fucking nightmare.
Rescued cats and then rescued cats but
only to take them on walks at Runyon.
Who takes a fucking cat on a
walking? She goes leash. Yeah.
She goes, do you like run yet? And
I was like, hey. And she's like,
let's go on a hike.
And then now I'm thinking taking a hike
with a girl with cerebral palsy with a
fucking cat. Like that is way
awesome. So they can't fix that.
We'll pause it as no,
no therapy for,
it's like diminished oxygen into
the parts of the body and it just,
it is what it is. It is what it is and
there's no way to fix it. You can't,
what if they exercise? Is that
possible? No, they can't exercise. No.
And I'm number one night we were laying
in bed in Scotland and I was like
scratching her bad arm and
I remember never bucking,
you know, there's like dude,
chill type moments and she
just leaned over. She goes,
you're not going to fix it.
Oh No. I was like, what? She goes, I can't
feel it. I can't feel it, so don't do it.
Oh, it's just like, uh, I can't leave
this kid. Check this one at the door.
Yeah.
That's brutal man.
It's brutal when somebody is angry
at a disability and you know,
you
don't have anything to say,
there's nothing you could say.
They just have to just absorb their
uncomfortable moment. She was so hot,
so hot. I can't even tell you. Wow. I
swear to got Angelina was opposing him.
Uh, I'd never fucked her.
I just got to or you know,
other stuff like what a blow job with
the good hand, with the good hand.
And she was a little bit of like,
did you have a couple of balls with a
numb hand? No, they just call up good cup.
But her ex boyfriend who had just gotten
out of prison called right after the
blowjob. It is, I'm telling you
what, it's kind of a prison.
It just got out of prison.
Did he call it like as you were
calming the phone rings a borderline.
I would say I was, I would all, I
would offer, I would offer it up as in,
I definitely was still in
bed and she got out like,
and it was brand new and he called and
they started fighting on the phone and I
went and I just was like, I'm out of
here. And she was like, what? She's like,
don't leave. And then he was, she's
like, nobody, go fuck yourself.
And then hung up on him. And I was like,
now he's definitely coming over here.
And then I was like, I'm fucking out of
here. I don't want no part of this drama.
It was also when I was like a massive
batch on, I just didn't want that shit.
I didn't want the fucking drama that came
with the girlfriend with one. I said,
oh, I was like, I'm in and
out of here. I'm fucking, no,
thank you. And she was like,
and I remember her saying something like,
I just had your dick in my
mouth or something like that,
like hit you in the center of the chest
and you were like, oh. And then, uh,
and then I walked home from sunset.
I was living across the street from
Andy Dick at the time. Oh No, no.
I walked down songs all the
way from sunset to fucking
meet wherever and he used
to live. No, there's in the
back of it like, you know, uh,
Beverly and Lausanne nigger like
right around there. And I've walked,
I walked home. I was like, I
don't want the fucking drama.
How long did that take?
It was a long walk,
but I was pretty hammer and I stopped
a few bars and I think nick sports and
yelled, yelled something. I said,
yeah, he stopped. Oh, walked in a bar.
Just rolling. Oh, Barb walked into
a bar before. Are you shitting me?
Best conversations you'll ever get into.
Fuck yes.
Especially you walking on your own.
Yes. Sit down. Yeah, all the time.
Brian, what? Walk into a bar and
sit down. Talk to a strangely.
Definitely by yourself all the time.
Hotels. What are you doing? Hotels. Oh,
I don't go to the ball. I go to the bar
and I sit down and fucking talk shit.
And have you ever die all the time.
You go to bars by herself at the time?
Definitely. I definitely do
that. Really? Yeah. If I'm bored,
I'll go to a bar and just hang out, look
at shifts, trying to find, pick up a girl,
you know, like just see what the
deal is. I'm going to have a beer.
I'm not going to sit at
home and drink a pair.
I'll have a couple of beers that have
never done. I'll have no Joe, Joe, Joe,
you got to, you know, kind of pool halls
with bars. It's just, it's the same thing.
It's the same thing. I got to
play pool, but yeah. All right,
well I was playing on my iPhone
world on Warcraft. Same thing. You,
but you, you, you would definitely
get a kick out of the way.
People just divulged shit
that you'd never tell people.
I do it at a hotel bars all the time now.
Like that's when he get drunk
woman stories. Yeah. And Yeah.
Oh look bad husbands like you want to
tell you about their bad husband's.
Half of my ex
girlfriends I met at bars is hanging out,
you know,
fucking hot chick dating her for a couple
of chicken, a bar to be blind. You Stud.
I've never been able to meet a chick at
a bar. That's how you have to do it. I I,
how else do you meet a girl like I, when
I lived in Columbus, Ohio, I was like,
all right. Uh, what else do I do?
I can go to the bowling alley.
That's my entire dating life outside
of college was doing standup.
I just met Greg seat standups.
Huge.
That's I think one of the best things of
stand out. So, so much better. So much.
So much easier than meeting the girl.
Going to a bar,
meet someone after a show and you have
something to talk about. Absolutely. Here,
the chicks I fucked while as low as the
stand up stand up one from Liverpool
whose tongue wouldn't go out of her mouth.
It wouldn't cause there was a piece of
skin connected from the bottom of my
mouth towards the tip of her tongue.
So hard time calling. She can,
she can do this. Is this like, oh
wow. So the whole time you kissed her,
you never got hurt you. You were just
looking for tongue fucking nightmare.
Yeah. The you ever had a nightmare can
just really in a big long tongues? No.
And she smoked and she drank Hennessy.
So I just,
the whole time I made out with her,
I was like,
this is what kissing Tupac would be like,
Hey,
you hear about the two pop pop porno,
the see these stills from that.
Joey said something about
it real. Yeah, it's real.
But even the other guy that's in it
that was like in a whatever digital
underground or whatever, he's like, oh no,
I knew about this tape for a long time.
Is he wearing the nose and
glasses too? No, not that guy.
Tupac.
Why don't you go from behind.
You're doing cause I'm about to ruin
your asshole. That guy was hilarious.
Whatever happened in that he was
a big producer. I heard. Really?
I think he's still produces probably.
Why wouldn't he keep producing cds of
his own digital underground was awesome.
I don't know.
I saw him once in a small bar,
like a really tiny bar and it was
when digital cameras first came out.
Now it's taking photos and all of them
are just blurry masses on one of them.
You can see like a blur and it knows from
him wearing that the humpty nowadays.
Oh that's Kinda cool. Yeah.
Was this a post success,
like they weren't famous yet,
right? Right. Yeah. It was just a small
little bit. He's still wearing the nose.
Fucking weird thing for artists.
For musical artists,
it's a totally different world for them.
It's so hard for them to get
their shit out to people,
you know now because of the Internet,
but back then you know you
needed the radio, you needed
the radio to pump you up.
That was the only way he got successful
and they would get successful for like
one fucking CD and then they'd be
gone and this CD and they'd be gone.
Eddie Bravo explained it to
me because he's a musician,
he knows a lot about the business and he
says that apparently what it is is it's
all so that the producers
can make a shitload of money
because the way contracts
are set up,
the first cds,
the producers make the majority of the
profits and then they basically say,
once you become a hit, then you become
a hit and then you make money on your,
you know, your next contract.
Commodity can makes total sense. Yeah.
Because the producers will make you,
they'll make you successful.
So they would do this and uh,
just pump and dump,
make a new one and get rid of him,
make a new one to get rid of him.
So they kept making all these hits.
The producers would make all this money,
but the artists didn't make nearly as
much money as they should have made.
And then their career
was over really quickly.
No one wanted to play their shit anymore.
Now they're not.
If you weren't in a record deal with
one of the big record companies and they
wouldn't play your shit on the radio.
Makes total sense.
You have an ability to make a hit.
Which one are you going to do it on?
The one you get no money or the one you
get all the money you make the one on
one.
All the ones you ever read.
There was a thing that Courtney love
wrote where she explained where the money
comes from. Some say that someone
else ghost wrote it, but uh,
that's probably just their hate and they
probably just don't realize how smart
she is, but she, I don't know. Maybe they
are. You think she's crazy? For sure,
but she's probably smart too. It's
definitely smart enough to get to work.
She might be, she dated
crazy guys. She's crazy.
But I think she's probably clever too. I
don't know. I'm just guessing. But anyway,
she broke down how,
where the money goes when someone gets
a record deal and where the, where the,
how the money flows down through,
you know, back to the artist.
And it's really pretty
ridiculous. I mean it's, it's a,
it's really incredibly stacked for
the record companies. But you know,
I mean that's, they have to put forth
the money. I mean, it's a business.
They're the ones who have to invest
the money in order to make the artists
famous. I mean, it is sort of a parasitic
relationship, but a certain point,
but it doesn't even exist
anymore. So what's the point?
You know, now all you do,
what you mean now really the,
the Internet is your friend.
That's what you want to do.
You want to get something where people
get ahold of it. It spreads virally,
you know, have a cool video, gets out,
it spreads virally and then you tour.
You know what I mean?
That's really the only way to do it now
towards where you make your money as an
artist. Yeah. I mean,
how many bands are just releasing
their shit for free online now?
They'll release their whole CD for free.
Right. Oh, fucking Wilco started all that.
Have you seen, I'm trying to break your
heart by Wilco. No, it's one of my,
one of my favorite documentaries ever.
The Wilco makes an album,
I guess what I'm going to say,
any big company named bigotry here,
Sony or whatever pays to make it.
They submitted,
the company says we don't
want it. Everyone gets fired
at the top of the company.
New Group comes on and they go,
don't worry, you can have it.
We don't even want it.
Wilco takes it out on tour.
That album releases it online for free
in this documentary on this documentary,
this is all happening and
then all of a sudden another,
like a subsidiary of Sony,
the big company buys the
album for like three times.
They originally paid to make it and it's,
it's really great documentary
and if you like Wilco,
it's a lot of their acoustic music,
but it's a great documentary,
but I don't even, you know,
Wilco is seriously never
heard of. They're great Joe.
There are a, it's a, it's
a, I would say, yeah.
I'm interested to see if you like
him or night. I like welcome back.
It's borderline that you
would like it. No, it's no,
they released their shit for free
online. No, not now. Not now.
They because it blown up and so you can
get some of their shuttle and free for
free online.
Jeff tweedy does is the lead singer.
He does living room shows where
he sits in the living room.
People pay a ton of money,
like a Google pay a ton of money.
They all chip in like say 10 grand
each to have him in his living room,
but then his,
he'll donate it to charity and it was
play acoustic in their living room.
He's an amazing guy. The
documentary is great. It is.
They say it's country music
but it's like modern countries.
Jason [inaudible] favorite band.
Really. It's really good. And, and,
and I'll turn you on the call again.
Wilko Wilko I'll make you a me
some mix tape of that sounds gay,
but I'll make you a,
but I'll,
I'll turn you on some tracks that you'll
like and then once you like those,
you'll start getting into, it's
definitely something you can get high too.
I think a lot of those specialty Yankee
Hotel Foxtrot and so these guys became,
what's that? Fox Foxtrot? The
first albums. Yankee Hotel
Foxtrot bloodhound gang.
Yankee Hotel Foxtrot. But it's a great,
I think you'll really like it. Dude.
Gawker apparently has a, uh, an article.
Exactly saying what I said, what everyone
is too polite to say about Steve Jobs.
Oh, tweet that shit. I'll
tweet it. I'll retweet it
as true to wow. It's
unfortunate. Whatever, man.
Nobody deserves to die of
pancreatic cancer. Fuck yes.
That's what I'm talking about as fuck.
That's amazing man.
When your body just fucking gives
out and fails you. But I do believe,
I do believe not to get on that same vibe,
but I do believe in negative
energy coming back to haunt you.
I know that I my could be, but I don't
think that's what did him, I like I said,
I think he worked too hard.
Really? Yeah. I think you,
you red line in everyday life, that guy
did and there's a lot of stress involved.
You know, it puts a lot of, put a lot of
pressure on himself to be the, you know,
how many hours do you sleep at night?
Me, I try to get eight. I really,
I'm a big stickler for that man.
I don't think it's good to not get sleep
every time I have and tried to burn
through the day with no sleep.
I feel like shit,
I make it a priority to try to take naps
wherever I can. You know, if I can't get,
you know, eight in a row, I
tried to get an aid accumulated.
I think it's one of the
most important things.
It's cause I know from exercise that
you can't exercise and not recover.
If you do, you're going to burn
yourself out. You're going to overtrain.
You need to recover. And that's what
sleep is, man. You have to recover.
You can't just burn it
every day. Eventually it'll,
you're, you fucking, you know,
you red line your machine too much.
Shit's gonna start breaking. Uh, yeah.
Like I feel mine breaking down. Do you
get eight hours sleep at night? No.
How close? It's hard when you have
kids too. I have a kid and a puppy.
I can't like we are,
I get,
I get up a couple times a night with
someone having a nightmare or the dog just
fucking one to eat my face.
And then, and then you,
and then I know even on the road now
I'm in that habit of like fall asleep,
wake up falsely of growing up. But I
also, um, I think I get that thing,
that sleep apnea shit. Of
course you did. And so I,
and that is been a big
proponent of me working out,
trying to get skinnier on the road. Just
some like, I don't want to fucking like,
I've been in bed where you're like,
and you're like, what the fuck?
Like my body just almost died. Right.
And I'm sleeping through it. Well,
you can die to some big football
player died just a couple of years ago.
Some big heavy dude. He's like in his
forties early forties died of sleep apnea.
Just stop or you used to sleep a lot and
now I will. Now I want to sleep more.
I want to get better. A better sleep.
Well again, shape the real thing man is
the alcohol. You know,
your, your alcohol, your,
every time you drink a beer you're
drinking a ton of negative calories,
you know, and it's just
empty, empty shifts,
energy. But I, but, but
I burn, I think I'm,
I'm not in the calorie wise.
I think I go through it.
Wait, that's the big thing
that was an empty calories.
I mean if you want to lose weight, it's
so simple. Eat a vegetable based diet,
eat a plant and vegetable,
the base diet.
Eat very few starches but a lot of salads,
a lot of, you know, really healthy,
fresh organic vegetables.
Drink a shitload of water and
wait to fly off your body.
Eat as much salad as you fucking
can get into your mouth, you know,
eat it to the point where you, you
know, you're completely stuffed.
You couldn't have another
bite. I mean it's gross. Nobody
wants to do it. You know,
you want to have a cheeseburger
is you want to have pizza.
That stuff's all delicious,
but that stuff takes a fuck of a lot to
break down and all the shit that we have
that has corn syrup in it and all the
shit that we have that has all sorts of
crazy carbohydrates and just, we're
just, it's so easy to get fat.
The American diet is absolutely
brutal, you know, and that bear shit,
I can help them,
but it's fun. We get the
problem. What am I going to do?
Am I going to sit and read? Yeah,
you do that too. I've been through,
I've been sober for big, long stretches
and I just go, so what, what do you like?
Go to the movies again, like
what do we do tonight? My,
we're just not going to talk and we'll
just sit here and be treated book.
You have a couple of glasses of wine and
you and your wife were like talking and
you're having a party.
It's like, it's like, hey,
you want to open a bottle
of wine with dinner?
And then you all of a sudden you
have a bottle of wine and she's like,
you're never gonna believe what happened.
I was at with Eila today.
And then you start laughing and then,
and then,
but we definitely have sober
dinners and you're like,
you wanna play scrabble tonight?
She's like, yeah. And he like scrap.
Oh, so you like get drunk
Dennis better puck. Yes.
How many nights a week here are
you getting lit up? Me? Yeah,
like in real real like seven, seven
nights a week and getting lit up. Yeah.
Wow.
But not lit up, but definitely
by, I would say by your standards.
If you were sitting next to me
as my body guard and Mexico,
you'd definitely be like lit up.
How many drinks are we talking
about every night? I don't know.
I can't like ballpark it that way. No, no.
I mean, I could do, hey, let's not get,
let's, let's not lie, but it's a
light day. If I have like four beers,
four beers I'll do, I won't even
feel it. And I'll just go to bed.
How dare you sir? Four beers. Four
beers. And I'm like fucking done. Wow.
Every night, man. No, no,
no. Don't worry about that.
I was doing that every night. I would
worry if I was getting lit up every night.
Yeah. But yeah, but we
could fucking seriously,
but there,
why are we doing this?
Can we go back and I know we just
got on a subject. No, no, no.
I said you don't drink every
day is what you're saying it.
I mean, I, I, like I said,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with a couple of drinks every day.
If you want to do it.
Yeah. Couple of the regular
guys put paper to me. Yeah, I
put that aside. That's you're going
to pay that. You gotta to pay for that
pay for what though? Health?
Like liver wise. Sure.
So does those taking sweaty
seven official oil pills a day?
It doesn't that fuck over your liver. No,
it doesn't fuck up your liver for food,
but you're,
you're taking so much supplements that
could fuck up your liver room or my
supplements.
I get my blood checked,
I know what I'm doing in
my by no you deal but,
but I didn't fuck your liver up alcohol,
vitamins or just food.
It's just broken down.
Food is not hard for your
body to process them at all.
That's a complete misnomer.
It's just not true. Yeah.
But if you're doing like, I dunno
like levels of vitamins. Yeah you can.
There's certain things that like fat
soluble vitamins that you could have,
you know that you take too much of
them and they get into your system.
But if you're getting your blood check,
do you know what you're doing?
If you know your dosage are, I'll get
my blood checked, my liver with be,
should everybody, should I go to a
checkup once a year and then, and I,
and you know my four beers are pounded,
like back to back to back the course.
Go do the first show,
second show, have a beer,
and then have a couple of
years out of the show. But,
and then I definitely
will say that I drink,
I would say more than
the average American,
100% but I have a different
lifestyle than the average American.
And I also spend my time differently
than the average American I, you know,
I'm not gonna I'm all for
thing that you do that might
not be so good for you,
that sort of kind of enhances your life.
And I think alcohol falls into that,
you know? I mean if that's
what you choose to do. Look,
all of my favorite people have either
had problems with drugs or you know,
or it could have a problem with
drugs where it wouldn't be.
So you had an alcoholic just anonymous.
Right now you're not telling anyone.
I hope. Why are you so angry
about alcohol? You know why?
Because Joey Diaz told
me you're an android.
Oh, there's a point of view on something.
It doesn't mean they're angry on it.
I don't,
I just said that I think that alcohol
is probably worth it because it enhances
your life enough to balance out whatever
damage is doing to your body. You know,
I think some of the most fun times
I've ever had has been buzzed.
I went with Aubrey,
we went to a country western
bar in Houston after the
show on Thursday night or
a Friday night rather.
And Houston,
we had a great fucking time
and the booze was flying.
We were doing shots every night, cause
I don't think it's healthy. I think
every night. No, no, no, no, no.
Your body suffers, man. If you,
if you get hammered every night, I believe
that your, your performance suffers.
I know it's suffers because I know
my set suffer. If I have a hangover,
my sets on stage, they don't, they're not,
they're not as good. If I'm hung over,
I know that hung over. You're
funny drunk. I'm funny as shit.
No drunk. I'm not funny. Really
drunk. I'm not funny drunk. Um,
I'm rambling and I'm,
and I,
and I don't know where I'm going and I
don't mean like hammers. No, no, no, no.
So, but like, but if I'm, if I'm hung
over and I have a cup of coffee, man,
my brain fires weird and it's funny as
shit. Really? Yeah. That's interesting.
I'm actually, I think I enjoy being
hung over than I enjoy being sober.
See, I think right away when
I'm hung over, I was always
thinking, what did you do?
Stupid.
Look what you did here.
I got through with him, you know, and I
say, I go buddy, let's get it back up.
We know we did to ourselves.
We're on the same team here.
Let's have a cup of coffee if we need to,
we'll do it.
Let's fucking write this boat.
Well, most of what I do is try to get a
light workout in and drink a shitload of
fucking totally work out.
And if I work out, it's gone.
The hangover grilling a
hundred percent never throw up.
Throw up if you from hangover.
Never
workout too hard though. You could Jack
Yourself. I've done that too. I've, uh,
I've had a Hong Kong,
I've been hung over and to decided I'm
just going to get a crazy workout in.
Yeah,
yeah. Fucking blow it out and then I'm
just useless than just kills me. Yeah,
that's dangerous.
No, I don't, I don't, you know,
obviously I'm talking about
ellipticals on a fucking hotel room.
Either that, man, let me tell
you some elliptical machine.
If you do it at a high level and
you do it a lot of intensity,
you should see I do elliptical workout,
a 40 minute elliptical workout dude,
where I have it all set up where the
first three minutes it's pretty light.
And then the second two minutes I pick
up the pace and then I go through these
intimate and sprints where I get up to
whatever the level is. That's the highest.
I'll jack it up to the highest and do
like a one minute wrestling match of death
with that fucking elliptical machine.
And then I'll drop it down to like half
the speed and I sprint and it's a bow
Rudel brutal workout to the point where,
and when I'm done,
sometimes my fucking hands are numb
from gripping the polls. I'm shaking,
my heart's pounding like I,
I've been drenched with sweat when I
was in Hawaii the last time I did it,
I had puddles to the left and the
right amount of elliptical machine.
You could get a fucking for Roche,
this workout in an elliptical machine,
you just gotta do it like a madman.
You can't do it like a pussy,
like Judah Friedlander.
Two to Freelander crazy is a
beast of a workout or elliptical.
Does he really like,
you almost think he's making fun of
people working on a little lipstick.
You're like, what the fuck is you
doing it for comic relief? No, no.
He's going to do the podcast soon.
So is David Tell David tells doing
their dog the fuck the last Tuesday in
October he's going to be doing it.
David [inaudible] best management
contacted me. It's so funny.
I don't think Dave has an email. He
doesn't have an email. I don't think so.
I wouldn't be shocked if he, you know,
Todd glass doesn't have an email.
Like I wouldn't be shocked.
No tog last send them an email.
I wouldn't even think talking about
she has a cell phone. You know what?
I think that's true because Todd glass
and I spoke on the phone once and he was
like excited to get me on the phone and
I think he said something crazy like I
don't have a cell phone
or I'd give it to you
and he made, maybe I'm, no, no,
no, no, you're accurate. I've,
because I've heard that but it tells
us it run is like his Twitter is like
please see Dave at and and his mind space
back in the day was like that and Dave
just isn't that guy nor Mcdonald's there.
Those guys are like old school in the
sense that they didn't see the benefit to
wasting, they're already
valuable time. What?
Cause they were famous before the whole
Internet ship blew up. I mean you're,
you're in that, you put out your brand. I
was thinking about this the other night.
I was like, your brand has been
your, was your brand? Well,
right when the Internet started,
like you're fucking your website with the
aliens and the fucking, and your blog.
I mean, how long did you keep
up with the fucking blog?
I've been writing a book,
so I haven't written a blog in
forever now for those asking,
I had a problem with a disagreement with
the people that wanted to publish the
book. They wanted to do
it different. And My,
my vision was to do my way of looking
at the world intertwined with how the
things that I've learned about how to,
to,
to control myself and operate
through life and, and, and the,
the perspective that I've gained on
how bizarre and strange just life is in
general. It's a very, it's
a very weird book, but it's,
a lot of it is really funny,
but a lot of is just really strange.
And when I brought it to them,
they didn't like the really strange stuff.
And then they don't know who you are.
Yeah. They wanted me to do, they actually
wanted me to do my standup. They said,
why don't you take your stand up and
just transcribe it? And I was like, Oh,
I'm going to send you some blogs like
you gotta you gotta read my shit.
And they're like, this is
brilliant writing. We love
it, but it's really not funny.
You're not trying to be
funny. And I'm like, yeah,
but there's some of them
that are funny like this,
these two of them sending you aren't here.
I'll send you a funny one.
We like this one. Can you make them
all like this? And I'm like, no,
I can't make them all like this because
sometimes there's some shit that I've,
I'm, I'm thinking of or I want
to talk about that isn't funny.
It just happens to be bizarre.
But that's the,
that is the,
the business of someone buying
into the brand of Joe Rogan,
not knowing what the brand
is like them going like
believe in a brand man.
You know,
you totally are a brand though.
I don't believe in a brand either.
I always believe,
but your brand,
I mean seriously it of all the fucking
comics I could want their brand to be.
Your brand is always reinventing itself.
It's always something new. It's over.
Whatever you find interesting.
Whether it's fucking, you know, dis,
you know back in someone who's a fan of,
of you on Newsradio,
it's MMA. Then it's the
podcast. It's marijuana is DMT.
It's all these interesting fear factor,
fear factor.
If you were going to put the
brand of the new Joe Rogan out,
the new brand would not go back
to fear factor, but you say, hey,
I fucking like that show.
It was a fun show to shoot.
I love those people and it was a
good show. That's the brand that's,
it's always reinventing himself, you
know, to be a brand where you go, I'm the,
I'm not going to say,
but like I'm the Mexican comic that
always has the Mexican parents.
I did the Mexican things.
That's what you're thinking
of brand when when you say,
I don't want to think,
believe in brand. Yep.
I'm just myself.
You know exactly what a brand,
it seems weird to call that a brand
when you're just yourself, you know?
Yeah. But despite, would you believe,
and I only know this from going on the
road and running into people that are
fans of your podcast,
there are a lot of people like you.
Yeah, of course. That's the,
one of the more interesting things
about this podcast is that all of us,
or reaching out to a bunch of people out
there that don't know anybody like us
but think like us and they,
they're surrounded by a bunch of
fucking morons and thinking a completely
different way.
And it's stifling.
It's stifling and it's depressing and
it just doesn't give him any hope.
And I can't tell you how many
times you've been on the,
and just this weekend and Houston
I talked to, I don't know how many,
literally hundreds of people who
told me that it changed their life.
They're like,
do to change my life.
It changed my life cause they know they
don't have it. It's not, they're not.
No one, no one is representing that
point of view out there in the media.
You couldn't do it on a regular
mainstream radio show. It's impossible.
You couldn't do it on a television show,
but despite that you couldn't even reach
out to the people that are listening to
you when they're listening to you.
Yeah,
like dude's got his headset and he and
his ears at target Sunday and I got
another car with my wife and he
goes, Holy Shit. Takes it out.
The fucking machine is listening
to your podcast in his ears.
Put fucking loading up carts.
You can't connect with any
of those outlets that way.
I had a power lunch with Alex Jones,
Brendan Walsh,
Doug Benson and Joey Diaz and Aubrey
from on labs and a four dudes from my
message board.
We had this power lunch and we're all
sitting in this Mexican place drinking
Margarita is before the fights and eating
burritos and it was just like I was,
I got some videos of it. Some of them
I can't show cause Joey Diaz once.
It doesn't want me to show him
some of the things that he said,
but they were absolutely hilarious, but
he doesn't want to get in trouble. But uh,
while, while we're having this lunch, Alex
Jones had the best point ever. He goes,
he goes,
you could take a TV camera,
turn it on a guy and him and his buddies
smoking a bong and it'd be the number
one show on CBS, put it on an 8:00 PM at
night. That's what people want to watch.
He was your, your broadcast
is that, that's what we want
to watch. And I was like,
you really could if
they had a fucking show,
if like some people and their buddies,
if they were funny,
they were really funny guys and it was
just a bong and the table and a room and
the living room and they're all sitting
around shooting the shit and they're all
intelligent and be the number one show.
Yeah. And it just call it
four guy spoken a ball,
four guys in a bong progressing a Bonk,
you fucking hit show.
I had at least two new
wants to do with it.
Talked about and then I tune
it again cause I go, oh shit.
They just figured out that if they
tied the bond with string on the roof,
they could swing it back
and forth to each other.
Well there's more of those people out
there then you would think there's more
people out there like those four
guys in a bomb. Then you would think,
and that's something like with the
podcast reaches and that's why you know
you've never had a venue like that before.
You know you've never had a connection
like that with all those people.
Like they'd want you,
they didn't,
they didn't know you were there and now
there's, they're happy. They found you,
you one of them.
It's like discovering
a good band and you go,
God is the first one
to find out that band.
Yeah,
but then we become mainstream.
They fucking hate you once you get
your first comedy central special.
We started selling out arenas
that it mad at you when,
remember when he was the machine dude.
Okay.
I was there in the early days.
Man. People love to have something.
That's a problem I have
on my message board.
Sometimes people love to be the people
that know about it first and it's like
new people will come on and then just
relentlessly towards the new people for
being new.
I've given up on that message board,
I just can't do it anymore.
It's kind of negative lately, right?
Yeah. It's just, it's like, you know what,
I could, I don't, I,
I'm trying not to be on the Internet as
much anymore so I'm not trying to just
to do, to stop dealing with
all the negative. Yeah.
Cause it's like I need to check out
tech news, I need to do this and that,
but I'm kind of done with the sharing
and the any more than I do already.
You know the guy in sharing
information. Yeah. Like I,
I'm tired of letting people
know who I am a little,
but you put it all out there so
far and I know you're dating,
I've kind of gone back a lot more than
normal. I'm not, not really doing it.
It's like I check Twitter maybe
once, twice a day. Now it's Facebook.
Forget about us because he'd becoming
famous. And as you're becoming famous,
you're dealing with a higher and higher
volume of haters. Stay in bed longer.
When you're famous, I've notice you
get, you get a lot of haters, man.
You know there's a lot of people that
get upset at you and Felix somehow or
another, they should be doing what
you're doing. That is a accurate, yeah,
there's some haters out there, man.
And you, if you're online all the time,
you're going to deal with those
people. You know, they're gonna,
they're gonna run into you when they're
going to fucking throw up shit on your
Twitter and you're going to look at it.
But the good news is you just,
it's good to know that people like that
exist and just hit that block button and
move along. I don't, I
don't even fuck with them.
Do you block people below blog young
buck anyway? No. Cause I don't have the,
I don't know people's spam dude.
I've had,
I've had crazy people spam
my entire timeline with like
10 messages in a row and
you're like, okay. And then you block
them. They come back as a different name.
It's like a never ending story.
It's so dumb. Yeah, dude, there's,
I wonder how many people are actually
trolling out there. You know,
maybe it's like,
I always like think it's like one dude
has been trolling me forever. Right.
I know Tom's occurs trolling me. Tom's a
gorgeous calling me that it wasn't true.
He told me he was trolling.
Know who he is. I know he has
because this, okay, you ready?
I'm going to find this girl.
She's got a tweeted me
and like pass two seconds.
Cause I know this is not a real person.
Oh, he's tweeting you with a girl.
All right. Here's what I got to tell you
her name. But here's what she tweeted me.
Oh, here's her profile. I love Bert
Kreischer get to meet Burton February.
I Love Zach Baggins great to
get to meet him in November.
And I was the first poll reply of Bert
Kreischer. This is what she writes.
And then she goes, uh, or
maybe exactly. I don't know.
She said today I got the ones,
she got it. She goes, yeah,
your birthday's coming up.
I'd love to give you a virtual blowjob.
And I was like and love
you miss you switch.
Like I know it's not a real
fucking person. Oh you know,
could easily be a real person she's
listing right now, but she's tweeting,
you know, she, if she goes, I believe
it's vice.com awesome podcast.
Can't wait to meet you. Sexy
machine. So she's totally listening.
I just thought you were sorry.
I thought you were not a real person.
Could easily be real. Yeah, it's actually
not. It's actually my girlfriend.
This is a lot of people out there that
are looking for someone to fixate on
buddy. They're looking for someone
to just lock their sights on.
Please find a pic of flying dildos.
And until then I'll visualize it in my
head forever as I think wants to be a
real person. I totally thought this
was a fucking one of my friends
lid. You're hilarious. Why would you think
you'd have someone obsessed with you?
Cause, I dunno, you didn't
fucking machine bro that,
but I'm just getting,
I'm getting this on the toilet saying,
so your birthday is November
3rd let me just say,
I'll give you the best virtual blow
job you've ever had. Gall love you.
Like I just go,
that can't be fucking with,
why would you think
that that was excellent?
It's gotta be fucking with,
why would you think that?
I think there's just some girl today
wants to suck your hog. No fellow bear.
You're so crazy a guarantee. You there's
a girl this and ladies and gentlemen,
this is your next task, Buck.
When you see Bert Kreischer,
when you see Bert Kreischer at
a comedy club, just say burnt.
I would love to suck your hog
and you could qualify that with,
if I wasn't married,
if I didn't have a boyfriend,
if I was in you weren't married,
Burt, I'd love to suck your hog.
Stop being so hard on yourself.
No, no, it's not hard on myself.
But if you read these tweets, I believe
the crazy person, he's fixated on you.
You're a hilarious guy and
she's enthralled by your talent.
And she wants to put your hog in her
mouth. Why is it so hard to believe?
What do you know in man, I was this
real fucking, come on man. I'm,
I'm wondering is this is, no, not that
I'm talking about your, your, you know,
you being 100%.
Someone like someone saying that to
me online. Adam, all the fucking 20,
30,000 people that follow me. The one
person that says that I go, all right,
this is Tom Segura cause no
one said that to me all day,
but one person said it was like, I'm
going to be honest. What bullshit
you to know if it's not fake humility that
you're crazy because you're hilarious.
I should expect
no, I get good emails. Oh, don't get me
wrong. I get good tweets of like, hey,
you're really funny. I'd love
you on the podcast. You're great.
When are you gonna go back on?
Why don't you have your own podcast?
None of them say,
I want to give you a virtual blow.
If I was a girl and I was working
in a diner in Dayton, Ohio, and uh,
just broke up with my man. Didn't
have a whole lot going on in my life,
but I love that podcast. I listened to
it on the treadmill every day and went,
Burke crashes on my God. He is so funny.
I almost peed my pants on that treadmill.
You know what I did? I got on
Twitter and I sent them a message.
Ooh,
Ooh.
I've met some of those people
that will send you crazy messages.
And then Claudia and Paul Chou and
trouble lick your ear and shit.
They're out there, dude. They're
real. Don't you wonder though,
if so one of the comics is
Kroger's, but he's like, well,
that's real simple then don't respond
to any of them other than fine.
So that's why I get, I want her to
find where all the time and go, hey,
thanks for the virtual budget.
Do you know dudes who are
obsessive? You? We all do.
We know do too obsessive about pussy.
And I have some friends that
I've thought about trawling.
I have some friends that I'd love
to put the boots to the slow.
I would have to accumulate
a lot of photographs of the
same girl though because
I'm going to have to like set up
if I'm going to do a real troll.
You gotta like accumulate
like a bunch of photos.
Didn't they do that to a hockey player?
I think there was like a hockey player
who was like kind of a famous because he
got in a brawl.
I don't remember the full story,
but a bunch of his teammates trolled him
with a fake account on my space and and
saved all his messages and then posted
it online or something like that.
That movie catfish is all about that.
Oh, is it really? I want his cat fish.
I heard a girl. No, it's not funny,
but no, no, no, not, not funny.
Good guy meets a girl
online.
Do you ever have that problem?
We can say things are funny because
it was a comic. No, it's really funny.
If something's good. It's funny. How
does that funeral hilarious. It's funny.
The guy meets girl in line on my space.
It starts going back and forth with her.
A Facebook goes back and forth with her,
goes back and forth with her,
and then he goes, and then his friends
are like, she doesn't, it's not real.
Let's go fucking finer.
Let's go find her.
And they go to find her and they go to
her mom's house in her mom's like, oh,
she's offered some friends. And they're
like, well, when will she be back?
And they're like, she's like,
oh, like in the weekend,
they can't get in touch with her. And
then his mom's like, she's in Rehab.
And she's like, really? And
he's like, yeah. And he's like,
there's something you don't wanna tell
me. By the way, if you've seen this,
haven't seen the movie. Stop listening
right now. Oh, then don't tell me anymore.
It's good. Oh, it's good. Scary. Yeah.
Don't say any more romantic.
Did you see red state? No.
You've got to see red state.
That's, you know, there's a movie.
That's a very interesting case
where, uh, I went to see it.
I really recommended it very highly.
It's a Kevin Smith's movie.
They're really takes you for a loop.
Totally didn't expect it.
I thought it was going to be a comedy.
Redstate is with Bruce Willis.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's the one with Tracy Morgan.
You're thinking of the cop movie. Oh No,
I was thinking more that Helen Mirren
and, and all of them. No, no, no.
Red State is a new movie that I'm Kevin
Smith made and he released it on his
own. He did the whole thing on
his own, shut off. He's like,
he's putting it in just a few theaters
so it can be considered for Oscar
nominations for,
especially from Michael Parks.
He's the guy who plays this incredibly
places preacher in the movie.
But uh, it's an interesting,
I fucking loved it, man.
I thought it was a great movie,
but like I look at the ratings
online 6.5 out of 10 and uh,
I talked to a lot of people and a lot
of people loved it and a lot of people
didn't like it at all. Really? Yeah, I was
shocked. What, what's the premise? Well,
it's kind of a convoluted premise,
but it's all about religious people
without giving away too much.
It's all about crazy religious people and
you know, and the fucking chaos ensues.
Gunfire and just, it's like, I
fucking love it. I love those.
It's a very terantin no asking movie,
you know, it's a very, you know,
you never know what the fuck
is going to happen movie.
And I enjoy the shit out of it.
What's your opinion, everyone?
I've been curious about the Hank
Williams junior with Emma, uh,
Monday night football debacle. Look, man,
people compare someone
to Hitler all the time,
but when you're on Monday night fucking
football and you start comparing,
you know,
republican playing golf with Obama,
like Hitler playing golf with Benjamin
Netanyahu, that's, that's first of all,
it's a weak sentence. You
know, like that's a stupid
thing to say. It's dumb. Like,
why would you, you know,
really that's the best.
Yeah, it's, it's, it's, you're trying,
he's trying to go for a bold statement,
but yeah, it's not saying
shit. Come on. I mean it's,
it's just too stupid and you're trying,
and here's the thing,
if he had just used a,
it's like Martin Luther King playing
with a negative person. I don't,
he should be fired.
I
think they're ridiculous.
I think, you know, if they
should look at it and go, well,
you know, he could say,
he should just say,
sorry I said that and that
would should be the end of it.
Should be their mom is not a bad guy.
He just said something that was dumb,
you know, I mean, he's
probably a tea party dude.
He's probably a conservative Republican.
I mean he's a country boy can survive guy,
you know.
So he probably thinks in his had
bet if he sat down, you know,
if somebody like fucking Christopher
Hitchens sat down with him and had him,
him break down what he sees
wrong with the, you know,
Obama and this administration
and its involvement overseas,
I bet every single fucking point would
get debunked and it would fall apart
right in front of his face have,
I bet he doesn't know what
the fuck he's talking about.
But it's fashionable right now to say
that this country is falling apart because
of Obama. One fucking asshole. I don't
even know the guy's name, nor do I care.
But he was on Fox News talking about
how Obama has done more to hurt this
country.
The nine 11 it was the dumbest
statement ever because then he goes,
you know, if we could have had total
victory, if we were allowed to,
you know, you know, when, when nine
11 happened, you know, it happened.
But then we went after them and we
went after them. We wouldn't have to,
who the fucking Iraqis
had nothing to do with it.
The innocent Iraqis are the
innocent Afghanis who had
nothing to do with nine 11
like what the fuck are you talking about?
You can say shit like that on TV still.
You can say shit like that,
but you can't call Obama Hitler.
You can't knock 11th in the
next like really bad word
though. It's like shocking.
This yogurt is nine 11 fuck get. Yeah, he,
I think he's totally crossed
the line but he's a moron.
He crossed the line on a moron. You know,
it's a, it's the, it's a more on premise,
you know, the premise of this one guy
is the one responsible for, you know,
more bad things than September 11th and
then he had some fucking crazy thing he
was saying about self reliance and I'm
no fan of this administration or any
administration, but I'm also not a fan
of people saying stupid Shit, you know?
You know what I mean? That's stupid
shit. Is it though? You know,
now that I think about it,
if he really wants to talk about what
America has done overseas, you know,
maybe I guess if you want to talk about
just volume of people killed, you know,
but you can't attribute that
all to Obama was the, yeah.
Do you get to a certain point where
you, I mean, how old do you know?
38 38 do you get to a certain point when
you look at guys like Obama and you go,
well that's guys just a few fucking
years older than me. You know, this is,
this is like, this is like my age.
People my age are running this,
this whole thing and who the fuck are
they? You know, and it ha, what is this?
I started doing that when I, when
people would leave my shows and I say,
thank you sir. When they'd
say great show. And then I go,
I'm fucking older than them.
Assert to, yeah, I'm a fucking sir.
And then I started thinking,
man,
my friends are like my friends or have
had great jobs, lost a, lost her house,
and then got good jobs to get.
Like my friends are grownups,
but I'm fucking child still. Yeah, but
you're allowed to be, you're a comedian,
you're an entertainer. Yeah,
100% I'm totally like, you know,
I'm 100% of responses,
but you know how you like look at
when you look at politicians, man,
don't you look at him as
being something different?
I always look them as being older,
wiser,
more experienced, more
educated, more this, more that.
But then as you get older and you realize,
well now I'm the same fucking age as
them. You know, Obama was a guy, the guy,
the guy that pulled the nice
secretary of of the side,
I'm sure his first day and was like,
just tell me who to shake hands with.
Just like everyone else. I mean, he's
a regular fucking dude. Maybe. I mean,
I don't believe that necessarily.
You think it's,
I don't think you can get to that
high level unless you're compromised.
I'm over exaggerating the statement, but
I'm saying he's like one of us. Like if,
if you get a job at a new place and
they put you in your new office and the
secretary comes in, she's like, would
you like coffee? He's like, look,
it's my first day. Like he was, he had to
be like that to whoever his advisor was,
right. You know, when they
started unloading shit,
he's like a guy that you can
relate to in a sense. 100%. Well,
I feel like anybody 10 years younger than
me and 10 years older than me in that
group, I can relate to
you. I know 10 years ago,
I remember that very well and I
can imagine 10 years from now,
so I can relate to that. But I don't,
when you, as I get to, uh, an older age,
like where I am right now, when
I look at it, I'm going to go to,
I can't relate to any of these fucks.
And these aren't really neat.
They don't represent me. These are, these
are crazy people. You know, their, their,
their spokesperson for corporations.
I don't know who fucking said this,
but it was a brilliant line that, uh,
I, for some comics had this, that um,
politicians should be forced to wear
jackets like Nascar drivers so you could
see their sponsors. Oh, that's fucking
brilliant. It's fucking brilliant.
I Dunno who it was. Whoever it was,
it said that bravo sir or ma'am,
but you're trying to relate.
You're trying to relate to them on,
on age and when in fact it's not,
it's not age,
it's just a kid's mindset. I know.
You're totally right. I, Ronald Reagan,
perfect example. I was the president. He
was the president. He's like a fucking,
he was like 60 years old or something,
whatever it was when he was a
president and you saw him on TV.
Like that's a wise guy who's been
around and he's taken a bullet.
He's fucking can ride a horse,
he can make a fence.
And then when he got in trouble with
selling arms to Iran, I remember that.
I remember when he was like,
I don't remember.
I don't recall when it was like all
that on TV. And everyone's saying, well,
Ronald Reagan maybe losing his mind.
He's an older guy and then he did,
but how bizarre was that when he
was on TV saying, I don't remember.
I don't recall.
Do you think he really didn't really?
Do you think Alzheimer's is kicking in?
Of course he had Alzheimer's.
Did he have it then the only
disease that doesn't make your rib,
I think between Nancy Reagan
and all the shit he knew,
it was probably just a
convenient way to check out.
I wonder if he just faked his Alzheimer's.
He said, you know what? I know too much.
The best way to get out of this and just
pretend like I'm fucking losing grip.
That's the best thing that I wrote.
We wait. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Let's get the cheeks. Wait, let
me go back to Ronald Reagan.
Faking all the gym. Imagine Nancy
Reagan said, just say no. Just say no.
Just say no. He's like, okay, okay.
Okay. Okay. I heard you. I heard you.
What's your name again? I heard you. Who
are you? Who are you? Why are you here?
Where's my pudding? He shows up at the
front door in his pajamas. He's like,
Ronald, did you get it out
of the house again? And he's
like, I was banging bowser.
But yeah. Did you sell arms
to Iran? I don't know. Did
I don't recall. You should.
We should eat showrooms or go
to the Ronald Reagan Museum.
There was a guy named Janie tingle
when I was a standup comedy,
very famous,
very respected comic from Boston back
in 1988 I was just starting out doing
comedy and I was an open miker and this
was just when the scandal was breaking
and he went on stage and he
goes, Mr President, he goes,
Lord knows I've forgotten some things I've
done. You know, he get home, you Hamad,
you can't find your fucking keys.
You know why your windows are open
and the air conditioning's on and it's
January. And he goes, but here's
just, just a little thing.
If you ever sell arms
to people who hate us,
jot it down and
make a little note.
Put it on your refrigerator.
When I remember at the time I was like,
like that is standup comedy.
Like what that guy he just nailed that
is the essence of standup comedy on there
isn't a sense though
cause he drew the picture
doing he impression of him.
I pictured a two story Boston flower
with the Windows Open and the keys and I
might have even made up although I
don't remember the bit but those,
that's how those guys worked back then
and then you know like cause what the
best part of that joke is is at the end
you're like what's the point I'm going
to be write it down, write
it, jot it down. The way
fucking brilliant.
That is that is stand up right.
It's like having making a
point and having it be funny.
How did you get me from a to B
in a way? This leaky way? Yeah.
You sneak it in to just make it
a little raindrop and effect.
I centered more in deposition.
Did you make a range?
Cause my cameraman on these beers this
entire time and I was just on your
nipples. What do you worry about that
stack of fucking beers in front of you?
It's for telling. It's telling
her it's nothing, right? No,
it was for nothing wrong with it, but
nothing. It's nothing wrong with it.
I told you it's worth it, but booze is
good. I have a card I need to give you.
The doctor will help you out a card.
We're indoctrinating you.
He's pretending that
this is an intervention.
He's pretending you gotta pee Brian.
Okay, Brian, why don't you go pee then?
I've already peed once. I'm tired of
being kind of a little girl. I gotta pee.
I gotta pee three. Should we just
end this thing or drink or pis?
Oh,
I have way too much pitch is
p. Wow. Brian, that's gay. It's
one thing to drink your own pee.
It's another thing to drink somebody
else's. That's, that's out of line.
Um, what's going on? Bert? Where are you
this weekend? Where can you plug 'em in?
Phoenix. Phoenix. Stand up
live. That's that giant place,
Huh? Yeah. I haven't been.
How many pieces? How many people does
that seat for me? Probably one 50 a shell.
That's a giant ass fucking place.
Yeah. I heard everyone loves it.
I think it's like gold standard.
Yeah. The Guy who owns the, uh,
West Palm Impromptu call Miami and Fort
Lauderdale. Yeah. He owns a lot of them.
Oh, Hollywood, right. Hollywood,
Florida. He is that one too. Is that for,
we'll our guy, what does that one for
number two, Hollywood? Yeah, it's high.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm in Fort Lauderdale,
the documentary shorts filming on Thursday
when I leave to go to the date and
then it ends in Tampa,
New Year's eve.
But we're doing all the way up
until my New York dates. Okay.
Find you. It's Bert
Kreischer, k, r, e, I s, c h,
e r on Twitter, B e r t e k r e, I s, c h,
e r and a Bert, Bert, bert.com
is his website. And uh,
this weekend I'm at the
Ontario Improv Friday,
Saturday and Sunday with
Joey Diaz and Brendan Walsh,
and we're fired up bitches and
it's almost sold out every,
and they get back from Austin, made it
back. You made it back. He fell asleep.
Poor Brendon cried.
I tried to wake him up.
We were out drinking the
night before and listen man,
you got to fucking keep a five
hour energy drink on standby.
You gotta throw cold water on your face.
You've got to pack before you go to bed.
Don't try to lie down.
Don't try to lie down and then wake up
five minutes before and throw your shit
in it. You'll never do it. You've got
to know how to learn how to travel.
You've got to learn how to learn.
Anyway,
Brendan's here and he'll be with us
this weekend at the Ontario Improv.
That's Friday, Saturday
and Sunday. And again,
that's almost all the shows or half
sold out today. And um, that's it.
We'll be back on Thursday with somebody.
I got to,
an author we're going to do and talk
about the power of the placebo effect.
That should be very interesting
to say. Posey. Um, Brian,
what do you got going on? Nothing.
Will, do you have a message for anybody?
Should they do please join my Twitter,
Twitter red band or it's subscribe
to us on iTunes death squad.
We have Brody Stevens and Esther.
Have their show now together. We,
I put the two misfits of desk
wired together into one show.
It's working out nice and
follow that on Twitter. And, um,
that's it freaks.
So we'll see you on Thursday.
Thank you everybody for everything and I
love you bitches. Yeah, see you soon. Bye.
Bye.
Okay.